bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition de
24 heures senna et elle a eu une cet
après-midi ouf de soulagement après le
fiasco du projet de réforme des
retraites rejeté à l'unanimité hier soir
en séance les sénateurs ont adopté ce
matin en commission le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ce
n'était pas gagné d'avancé mais il ya
urgence à combler le déficit de la
sécurité sociale écoutez il donnait ni
rapporteur du budget de la sécu ici au
sénat suivi de la réaction du sénateur
alain milon pour lui
c'est donc l'autre système de protection
sociale il ne peut vivre que s'il est
équilibré et donc la persistance de
lourds déficits le mettrait en danger et
mettrait en danger sa crédibilité c'est
pour ça que le gouvernement avec
ténacité je crois décourage avec
responsabilité
chaque année fait adopter un certain
nombre de mesures qui progressivement le
font revenir vers l'équilibré le
gouvernement autorise une augmentation
de la consommation
sanitaire dans notre pays à plus de
quatre milliards par rapport à l'année
passée c'est donc selon nous un peu trop
fort et on pense que l'ensemble des
acteurs de la santé qu'elles soient des
hôpitaux qui soit dans le privé qui soit
dans la ville s'apprêtait comme tout le
monde dans le pays à faire un effort
pour avant une consommation moindre
l'économie sociale et solidaire
peut-elle être un remède à la crise
benoît hamon présente aujourd'hui en
séance son projet de loi le ministre a
rappelé aux sénateurs la détermination
de l'exécutif à faciliter la reprise
d'entreprise par les salariés ont
rejoint tout de suite tu aimes tran huy
en direct de l'hémicycle bonjour table
bonjour delphine alors quels sont les
enjeux de ce texte sur l'économie
sociale et solidaire mais écoutez
delphine ce texte fut d'abord office de
textes fondateurs parce qu'il définit ce
qu'est l'économie sociale et solidaire
c'est une manière d'entreprendre qu'il
ne cherche pas le profit à tout prix qui
réinvestit ses bénéfices dans
l'entreprise et dans la gouvernance et
démocratique mais
eh bien ce n'est pas que cela puisque le
texte reconnaît aussi l atout
fondamental que représente l'économie
sociale et solidaire on l'économie
française s'est en effet 10% du pib une
croissance de 23% en disant ces
dernières années et c'est l'une des
réponses du gouvernement à la crise une
réponse qui cependant ne satisfait pas
tout le monde l'une des dispositions du
texte suscite une véritable levée de
boucliers du patronat cette disposition
elle se trouve aux articles 11 et 12 et
elle prévoit l'information préalable des
salariés en cas de cession d'une
entreprise afin de permettre à ses
salariés de reprendre l'entreprise plus
facilement pour le patronat c'est une
véritable atteinte à la confidentialité
nécessaire au rachat de toute entreprise
écoutez la réaction de thibault lanxade
du medef il est au micro de quentin
calmait
quand on vend une société une
confidentialité très forte et à se créer
il est répété à 2,5 personnes un salarié
c'est quoi c'est une personne qui est en
contrat à durée déterminée ou
indéterminée c'est un contrat
d'apprentissage de l'alternance ça
concerne toutes les personnes qui sont
dans l'entreprise donc cette clause de
confidentialité alors vous croyez que le
patron il va il se retourner contre le
salarié qui aurait fuité comment on va
savoir qu'il affûté et on va l'attaquer
de cole juridiction devant le conseil
des prud'hommes pas tout ça tient pas la
route
l'ump est sur la même ligne que le
patronat et évoque quant à elle un
projet de loi qui crée une véritable
distorsion de concurrence avec des
entreprises
merci beaucoup au tam pour vos
explications alors sans plus tarder et
bien direction l'hémicycle du sénat pour
écouter l'intervention du ministre
benoît hamon et on se retrouve à 19h
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi relatif à l'économie
sociale et solidaire
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à monsieur benoît hamon ministre
chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la consommation
monsieur le président
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques
adam g messieurs les rapporteurs
et mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
le projet doit quand même j'ai l'honneur
de présenter au nom du gouvernement
constitue un acte fondateur pour la
reconnaissance d'une part importante de
notre économie nationale et de ses
acteurs et exprime la volonté du
gouvernement de soutenir un mode
spécifique d'entreprendre et de
souligner la contribution décisive de
l'économie sociale et solidaire à
l'existence de solidarité bien ancrée
dans la vie sociale de notre pays ainsi
qu'à la création de richesses en france
cet engagement du gouvernement en faveur
de l'économie sociale et solidaire est
tout d'abord le fruit d'un constat
celui qui consiste à reconnaître que la
crise économique est aussi une crise du
modèle entrepreneurial
la financiarisation de l'économie
mondiale implique en effet une
dépossession de la gouvernance
économique que ce soit au détriment de
la sphère politique
ou de celle des organisations sociales
le pouvoir qui régit la vie économique
n'a jamais été plus abstrait pour les
salariés alors que certains magnifique
entreprise comme collectif humain et
c'est parfois souvent même une réalité
une autre réalité celle d'un pouvoir
dans l'entreprise qui n'appartient plus
aux salariés et aux citoyens s'est
développée
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que le
sentiment de bon nombre de nos
compatriotes et pas simplement de me
compatriotes et que la décision dans le
champ économique appartient de moins en
moins aux états souverains de moins en
moins au collectif humain est de plus en
plus à les faire qui leur apparaissent
lointaine et abstraite
plus que jamais donc la question de
savoir à qui appartient
de décider de nos vies est une question
fondamentale dont aucun citoyen ne peut
s'affranchir dont aucun gouvernement ne
peut non plus à franchir décidé ce n'est
pas seulement voter dans le cadre
d'élections politiques démocratiques
décidé c'est conserver la maîtrise de sa
vie que ce soit pour les grandes
affaires du monde et de la nation comme
pour celle qui impacte le quotidien en
commençant par le travail
si beaucoup aujourd'hui et prouvent
parmi nos compatriotes le sentiment et
même la peur que la maîtrise de nos vies
nous échappe c'est parce que nous
perdons de vue l'horizon de nos
décisions et parce que nous abandonnons
parfois l'ambition de décider
collectivement chacun en quelque sorte
prime sur le collectif
franck laroze elle disait chacun de nous
a appris les gloires de l'indépendance
que chacun de nous apprennent désormais
les gloires de l'interdépendance
nous devons reprendre le goût l'habitude
la nécessité de l'interdépendance
force est de constater hélas que dans
les dix dernières années
le moteur de l'économie mondiale le
moteur de l'économie européenne le
moteur de l'économie nationale a
davantage reposer sur l'apa individuelle
du gain que sur les choix économiques
collectifs de long terme
en quelque sorte la finalité même de
l'action tend à s'effacer derrière la
satisfaction immédiate de cette action
la morale commence ou fini l'intérêt
écrivait quand
et quelle est la morale de notre époque
quelle est la morale de notre époque au
terme de la crise financière que nous
venons de vivre
c'est l'appât du gain qui motive la
diffusion massive des produits
financiers diffus dérivés
c'est l'appât du gain qui plonge dans le
surendettement des millions de ménages
manipulés par des vendeurs de crédit
sans scrupules c'est l'appât du gain qui
transforme ceci en bulles spéculatives
puis en crise financière mondialisée
c'est enfin l'appât du gain qui au bout
de la réaction en chaîne impose des
politiques d'austérité pour financer des
dettes privées à la lumière de cette
crise je doute qu'une aspiration morale
ait pu freiner la recherche effrénée de
l'intérêt privé je vois bien en revanche
en quoi
l'aléa moral à trouver à s'illustrer et
jamais la définition qu'en a donnée à la
dame smith sonner si juste l'aléa moral
et la maximisation de l'intérêt
individus elle sans prise en compte des
conséquences défavorables de la décision
sur l'utilité collective
s'il faut donc conserver le pessimisme
de la raison il faut surtout pas
abandonner l'optimisme de la volonté
car à contrario et c'est ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui il faut bien
observer que les constructions
économiques qui ont su préserver leur
dimension collective qui n'ont pas
ériger la lucrativité en principe absolu
et qui ont maintenu leurs exigences en
matière de responsabilité sociale ces
entreprises là ont montré une résilience
particulière dans la crise économique
mieux les organismes qui se caractérise
ainsi sont aujourd'hui ceux qui
proposent le plus souvent des réponses à
des besoins sociaux qui ne s'en
satisfait ni par le marché ni par le
secteur public besoins sociaux d'autant
plus cruciaux aujourd'hui que la crise
est venue frapper nos compatriotes
pourquoi cette résistance
parce que ces organismes sont pour
l'essentiel des sociétés de personnes
libérées de la pression des capitaux
investis grâce à l'égalité des apports
de leurs membres
parce qu ils sont les héritiers d'une
longue d'histoire économique et sociale
à certains égards antérieur et
aujourd'hui parallèle à l'autre économie
c'est-à-dire l'économie capitaliste
parce que ces organismes ont su demeurer
des personnes morales au sens plein du
terme
certes les entreprises de capitaux sont
aussi des collectivités humaines et
l'épanouissement au travail la
responsabilité sociale l'efficacité dans
la réponse aux besoins ne sont pas
nécessairement moins absente que dans
les sociétés de personnes mais il ya une
chose qui appartient spécifiquement
sociétés de personnes et qui ne peut
leur être contestées
c'est l'égalité qui règne entre les
membres constituant la société
indépendamment de leur apport financier
cela ne fait pas tout mais cela signifie
que la prise de décision ne peut y être
motivés par le seul intérêt financier en
ces temps de financiarisation extrême de
l'économie
cela compte c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait
la force de l'économie sociale tout au
long de sa patiente maturation car il ne
s'agit pas d'une mode économique liée au
temps de crise pas plus qu'il ne s'agit
de la remettre dans l'air du temps avant
d'être promise à disparaître très vite
une fois la croissance revenue
le ss est une économie à part entière
qui innovent et qui se développent les
principes fondamentaux l'économie
sociale et solidaire sont au coeur de
l'activité économique depuis son origine
et il trouve à s'illustrer sur tous les
continents quel que soit le niveau de
développement des pays considérés en
france et dans bien d'autres pays
européens les acteurs de l'économie
sociale que sont les mutuelles les
coopératives et les associations ont
bien souvent précédé la création de
services marchands ou de service public
je ne sais pas si c'est autorisé de
faire monsieur le président mais je
voudrais saluer parmi le public les
représentants de ces grandes familles de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui me
font l'honneur d'être ici aujourd'hui
présents au sénat pour à l'occasion de
l'examen en première lecture au sénat du
texte sur l'économie sociale et
solidaire
en france et donc bien d'autres pays
européens les acteurs de l'économie
sociale que sont les mutuelles les
coopératives et les associations ont
bien souvent précédé la création de
services marchands ou de service public
parce qu'ils ont su avant d'autres
identifier des nouveaux besoins parce
qu'ils ont su mieux que d'autres définir
les conditions d'une réponse collective
et mutualisé parce qu'ils ont su plus
efficacement que d'autres organiser la
solvabilisation de cette réponse les
moteurs de cette histoire n'ont rien de
spécifique à la france même si notre
pays même si dans notre pays l'économie
sociale a épousé de façon originale nos
structures économiques et sociales la
recherche scientifique valide en effet
le fait que sur tous les continents il
existe une économie différente de
l'économie capitaliste qui coexiste avec
elle et qui se font toujours sur au
moins deux exigences fondamentales
la première c'est la gestion en commun
collective de la structure en associant
ces participants au prince sur le
principe une personne égale une voix et
non pas sur cet autre principe celui de
droits de vote proportionnel à la part
de capital détenue
la deuxième exigence fondamentale
c'est le consentement volontaire à une
limitation de la lucrativité de
l'activité au nom de la poursuite
d'objectifs sociaux de prévoyance et de
mutualisation mais parce que cette
économie c'est naturellement investi
dans les activités solidaires au service
des personnes vulnérables et des
territoires délaissés elle est parfois
et j'ai eu l'occasion souvent de le dire
résumé en économie de la réparation rien
n'est pourtant plus faux puisque des
pans entiers de notre économie ne
seraient pas ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
s'il n'avait pas été fondée sur les
principes de l'économie sociale et
solidaire protection sociale accès au
crédit aide à domicile production
agricole tourisme de masse grande
distribution recyclage services aux
entreprises action sanitaire et sociale
la contribution des entreprises et
organismes appliquant les principes de
la ss est constitutive du modèle social
et républicain francs notre économie ne
serait tout simplement pas ce qu'elle
l'est sont les entrepreneurs collectifs
qui ont créé les mutuelles et les
coopératives que nous connaissons tous
dans notre vie quotidienne sont que nous
identifions toujours leurs spécificités
d'organisation cet esprit d'entreprise
ne s'est pas essoufflé à bien des égards
l'action des entrepreneurs de l'économie
sociale et solidaire demeure fidèle à
l'exhortation de charles gide l'un des
principaux inspirateurs du mouvement
coopératif en 1885 qu'il écrivait dans
le journal l'émancipation le premier
d'une série de 600 articles son titre ni
révolté ni satisfait son programme créé
par la coopération un ordre supérieur
j'ouvre les guillemets qui ne serait pas
le résultat spontanée des lois
naturelles et comme tel amoral mais le
résultat d'efforts coordonnés inlassable
vers un idéal qu'il faut montrer au
peuple c'est mon du souffle il nous
aspirons il exalte aussi l'esprit
d'entreprendre mais entreprendre
collectivement je regrette d'ailleurs
parfois souvent même que le grand public
les médias les pouvoirs publics
eux-mêmes et surtout certaines
organisations patronales ne valorise que
l'idée selon laquelle il n'y aurait de
vrais entrepreneurs qu'individuel
pourtant les entrepreneurs collectifs
que sont les sociétés personnes sont
solides elles sont robustes elle innove
elles recrutent elles forment l tiff le
lien social
mieux elle invente un autre monde une
autre façon d'agir en économie je me
perds écrivait entreprendre consiste à
changer un ordre existant l'économie
sociale et solidaire
incontestablement participe de cette
oeuvre de changement je les ai déjà dit
et je le répète encore devant vous je ne
souhaite pas opposer un modèle un autre
une bonne à une mauvaise économie et
j'ai jamais cru qu'il y avait dans le
esse esse une économie préserver de
toutes les turpitudes quand le reste de
l'économie serait-elle ouverte à tous
les maux
la réalité cependant c'est que
l'économie sociale et solidaire est trop
longtemps rester à la marge des
politiques nick est trop les entend
rester à la marge de la reconnaissance
de son rôle et de son originalité au
sens où elle est capable d'associer
performances économiques utilité sociale
et impact environnemental c'est la
raison pour laquelle
au delà de cette paresse intellectuelle
à laquelle on peut tous
ces départs fois j'ai souhaité et le
gouvernement a souhaité avec jean marc
ayrault et le président de la république
également permettre et donner les moyens
à l'économie sociale et solidaire de
changer d'échelle et je veux bien sûr
parler de ces entrepreneurs qui en dépit
des difficultés quotidiennes et la
concurrence difficile acharné parfois
maintiennent l'esprit des origines dans
leurs organismes et entreprises de
l'économie sociale je vais aussi parler
de ceux qui se lancent dans la création
d'activité en faisant le choix de partir
de pas grand chose peut être mais avec
des valeurs et des principes je veux
donc inclure c'est l'ambition du
gouvernement dans notre ambition
collective ce foisonnement d'entreprise
social dont les modes de production et
de redistribution des bénéfices emprunte
aux principes de l'économie sociale et
solidaire leurs fondateurs revendiquent
la dénomination d'entreprise sociale au
nom de la priorité donnée à leurs
activités sociales dans la définition de
leur entreprise mais aussi en adoptant
dans l'immense majorité des cas les
règles qui caractérise le ss cette
évolution illustre
l'importante créativité du secteur qui
s'est associé principes de gestion
principes de gouvernance et utilité
sociale tout en incarnant les
aspirations les plus innovantes des
formes d'entreprendre dans un souci
constant de bien commun l'apparition de
ces nouveaux acteurs incarnent le
mouvement permanent de l'économie
sociale et solidaire elle est
aujourd'hui celle ci l'économie sociale
et solidaire mur pour changer d'échelle
c'est donc l'ambition du gouvernement
que de l'accompagner dans ce changement
d'échelle car ces caractéristiques
contribueront naturellement à la co
construction d'une stratégie de
croissance plus robuste plus riche en
emplois plus durables et plus juste
socialement elle s'appuiera sur la
formidable diversité et la richesse
d'une économie authentiquement populaire
dams et messieurs les sénateurs jean
vient à présent au contenu du texte et à
sa méthode d'élaboration il le fruit
d'une large et intense concertation
conformément à la volonté du président
de la république visant à promouvoir le
dialogue social et civil une large
consultation des acteurs de l'économie
sociale et solidaire a été conduite pour
l'élaboration de la présente loi et
s'ils sont ici aujourd'hui c'est que à
bien des égards cette loi leur
appartient déjà et j'imagine qu'ils
feront leur encore plus au terme des
débats que nous aurons ensemble j'ai
sollicité les acteurs eux-mêmes et leurs
fédérations professionnelles qui ont
fait preuve d'une importante et
inlassable disponibilité ce dont je les
remercie sincèrement est aussi mis à
contribution les instances consultatives
notamment le conseil supérieur de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et les
institutions représentatives du secteur
le conseil des entreprises et
groupements d'employeurs de l'économie
sociale le cges j'ai également associés
volontairement les organisations
syndicales de salariés qui avaient
logiquement leur mot à dire quant à la
vigueur des principes dans la réalité
sociale des entreprises et des
organismes de jeunesse par ailleurs le
conseil économique social et
environnemental a fait l'objet d'une
saisine du gouvernement son âme vie fait
notamment l'objet d'une reprise assez
exhaustive concernant la modernisation
du droit coopératif et la
territorialisation des politiques de
développement d'économie sociale et
solidaire enfin la présente loi
s'inscrit dans le cadre de l'initiative
de la commission européenne pour
promouvoir ce secteur comme acteur à
part entière d'une économie sociale de
marché hautement compétitive plus
généralement cette loi vise à faire de
l'économie sociale et solidaire un
modèle solide et conquérant elle vise à
conforter sa place au sein d'une
économie plurielle en synergie avec les
initiatives européennes à lever les
obstacles à son développement et à
prévoir les dispositifs visant à assurer
le déploiement et la croissance de ces
structures sur les territoires j'en
viens à présent principaux débats
ouverts par l'élaboration de la de cette
loi je m'attarderai pas en détail sur le
contenu d'un texte sur lequel le
rapporteur j'imagine reviendra lui même
et et vous-même mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs également je veux
simplement resituer les sujets essentiel
de débats et les contributions de vos
rapporteurs et de vos groupes respectifs
les acteurs de l'économie sociale
souhaitait une reconnaissance publique
de ce qu'ils font cette volonté de
reconnaissance de leur apport à
l'histoire économique et sociale
française comme à la prospérité à la
cohésion sociale du pays est au coeur de
l'organisation représentative que se
sont donnés les acteurs de l'ess faute
d'une définition légale les englobant
tous ces acteurs en progressivement
sélectionnés par eux mêmes les
déterminants une définition politique
faute d'une administration d'appui qui
soient pérennes ils ont construit des
outils dont ils ont besoin tant en
matière d' expertise que de financement
la création d'un ministère délégué es s
placé auprès du ministre chargé de
l'économie et des finances constitue
donc un tournant important pour
l'organisation politico administrative
du secteur mais aussi pour sa
reconnaissance publique ce sont donc
avant tout les caractéristiques
économiques des entreprises et
organismes concernés qui justifie le
choix d'une reconnaissance ministérielle
même si elles ne suffisent pas pour
définir l'identité ni l'utilité sociale
les acteurs de l'économie sociale avait
donc besoin d'une définition de ce
qu'ils sont les débats sur la définition
de le ss qui constitue l'article 1 de la
loi auront été dense entre nous ainsi
qu'avec les acteurs pendant la phase de
préparation de ce texte ils le seront
encore dès cet après-midi et ce soir
pendant notre débat mais c'est
parfaitement compréhensible concernant
une identité qu'il s'agit de données en
s'appuyant tant sont des considérations
philosophiques que sur des réalités
juridiques à ce titre le projet de loi
entend affirmer que l'économie sociale
et solidaire se définit de façon
incontournable par l'intégration dans
les statuts des entreprises et
organismes concernés les principes
communs suivant un but poursuivi autre
que le seul partage des bénéfices une
gouvernance démocratique participative
défini par des statuts et incluant les
parties prenantes et enfin une gestion
mettant en oeuvre les modalités d'une
lucrativité limitée ou encadrer
l'application de ces principes permet
aux entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire de démontrer qu'il est
possible
à contre-courant de l'économie
financiarisée de se développer librement
en s'appliquant des règles
contraignantes qui n'ont pas d'autre
finalité que de replacer l'homme au
coeur de l'économie ainsi défini
l'économie sociale et solidaire
intégrera donc aussi bien les organismes
historique se définissant par leur
statut que les entreprises nouvelles
faisons le choix des principes communs
de ss avec cette définition inclusive
c'est tout le ss qui se trouve mise en
mouvement j'ai souhaité que ce mouvement
soit compréhensible du grand public en
proposant aux acteurs de souscrire à une
déclaration de principes de l'économie
sociale et solidaire je propose qu'elle
soit rédigé par le conseil supérieur
mise en oeuvre est contrôlé par les
acteurs eux-mêmes cette déclaration sera
l'illustration que le mode
d'entreprendre commun toutes les
familles se traduit par des pratiques
différentes de l'économie de capitaux je
suis convaincu que cette déclaration
sera une chance pour les entreprises et
organismes parce que je sais aussi
que s'il existe des entreprises de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
la vie des employeurs de le ss ne suffit
pas a résumé l'avis du collectif des
entreprises de l'ess raison pour
laquelle il me semble que les
entreprises de le ss doit à nouveau
jouer ce rôle moteur en matière de
relations sociales et faire en sorte à
deux portes et des exigences qui sont
des exigences fortes dans leur
fonctionnement la définition de
l'économie sociale appelée aussi celle
de l'utilité sociale c'était un sujet
fondamental de nos travaux préparatoires
en effet l'appartenance à l'économie
sociale et solidaire au titre de la
définition que nous en donnant dans
l'article 1 mais aussi au regard de la
réalité des entreprises et organismes
qui la composent ne suffisent pas à
qualifier leur utilité sociale la
spécificité du mode d'entreprendre ne
préjuge pas nécessairement de la
finalité de l'action c'est pourquoi nous
avons fait d'une part nous avons d'une
part fait le choix d'une démarche ti par
la définition l'utilité sociale
justifiera des droits nouveaux notamment
en matière de financement d'autre part
nous avons fait le choix de nous reposer
sur un agrément existants l'agrément
solidaire en l'adaptant plutôt que d'en
créer un nouveau le travail de fond de
la commission des affaires économiques a
permis d'affiner la rédaction du
gouvernement pour que les conditions
futures de mise en oeuvre de l'agrément
solidaire soit parfaitement adaptée aux
entreprises qui ont vocation à y entrer
cet agrément pourra donc être ciblée sur
les entreprises à forte utilité sociale
qui éprouvent le plus de difficultés à
accéder à des financements de marché
votre commission a également fait le
choix d'introduire une définition de
l'innovation sociale s'agit d'une
avancée majeure qui répond pleinement
aux initiatives du gouvernement puisque
cette définition permettra demain à la
doctrine du futur national du futur
fonds national d'innovation sociale de
pouvoir identifier les projets qui sont
innovants sur le plan social et qui
pourront être ainsi financé par la
double contribution qui sera celle de
bpi france et des régions qui abondent
ce fonds d'innovation sociale il était
essentiel que nous avancions dans une
définition d'innovation sociale la
contribution du sénat et la commission
des affaires économiques est à ce titre
tout à fait décisive la structuration de
ss étaient nécessaires afin aussi
d'organiser le dialogue avec l'état le
gouvernement a donc fait le choix de
reconnaître l'utilité peut lui public
des chambres régionales de l'économie
sociale et solidaire et il a confié aux
représentants territoriaux l'aide de
l'état la charge de contractualiser avec
elle afin qu'elles assument plusieurs
missions publiques qui font aujourd'hui
défaut ces crèches les chambres
régionales de l'économie sociale et
solidaire se verront donc demain charge
et non seulement d'assurer la promotion
d'économie sociale et solidaire
d'assurer un appui à la formation des
dirigeants et salariés des entreprises
mais elles seront aussi chargés
d'assurer le suivi statistique des
entreprises qui se réclament de la ss ce
pourquoi elle dispose déjà d'une
capacité d'expertisé incontournable en
leur donnant la capacité d'ester en
justice aux fins notamment de faire
respecter aux entreprises commerciales
les conditions prévues à l'article un
voulé renforcerait dans leur légitimité
et dans leur mission fédératrice et
c'est une excellente initiative vous
avez également choisi de confier au csss
le conseil supérieur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire la mission de
rédiger de faire vivre une déclaration
de principes de l'économie sociale et
solidaire les entreprises et organismes
y adhéreront librement mais cette
déclaration de principe permettra assuré
pont de répondre à certaines
interrogations voire à certaines
exigences liées hymne de nos concitoyens
quant à la plus-value spécifique de
l'économie sociale y compris je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure en matière
d'exemplarité sociale le renforcement de
l'ancrage territorial et l'articulation
de l'économie sociale et solidaire aux
politiques publiques locales constitue
un autre facteur indispensable à la
réussite du changement d'échelle de
cette économie les dispositions de la
présente loi ont donc également pour
objectif de renforcer la capacité des
acteurs locaux à coopérer pour autant
les pouvoirs publics ne doivent pas en
prendre prétexte pour se désengager mais
au contraire chercher les convergences
les plus fécondes avec la société civile
le gouvernement n'a pas fait le choix de
privilégier un échelons de collectivités
territoriales plutôt qu'un autre il est
indéniable que les collectivités
territoriales ont 20 ans d'avancé sur
l'état en matière de développement de le
ss je connais et je salue l'action des
régions en cohérence avec leurs
compétences en matière de développement
économique mais d'autres collectivités
agissent aussi et le gouvernement ne
souhaitent pas faire le tri entre elles
alors même qu'il est souhaitable que la
mobilisation en faveur de l'économie
sociale soit le fait de tous je pense
notamment au rôle déterminant des
départements dans le financement de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
les conférences régionales que vous avez
institué par un amendement serait seront
le bon niveau pour évaluer les efforts
de chacun et clarifier ce qui devra
l'être ultérieurement dans la
répartition des compétences par ailleurs
votre commission des affaires
économiques a décidé de permettre au
parlement de se prononcer sur des points
qui pouvaient apparaître au conseil
d'état comme de nature infra
législatives mais qui eu égard aux
enjeux qu'ils sous-tendent nécessité
d'être inscrit dans le projet de loi il
en va ainsi de l'accompagnement et la
professionnalisation des entreprises de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
notamment des associations par la
reconnaissance législative des
dispositifs locaux d'accompagnement les
dna qui se voit donc intégrer un
dispositif global de soutien à l es s
son préjudice de leur axe de de leurs
actions auprès des associations céder à
la en fait leur preuve au moment de la
mise en oeuvre des emplois jeunes et ils
sont aujourd'hui encore très sollicités
pour les emplois d'avenir ce qui atteste
de leur efficacité et de leur légitimité
il y aura donc demain
de même pour la commande publique
responsable avec la possibilité pour les
préfets de recourir au facilitateur de
clauses sociales que sont notamment les
plans locaux pluriannuel pour
l'insertion et l'emploi les plis et les
maisons de l'emploi sur le même sujet de
la commande publique vous avez souhaité
ajouter un article sur les marchés
réservés en opérant une transposition
anticipé en quelque sorte d'une
directive relative aux marchés publics
dont l'adoption est imminente au niveau
communautaire c'est un débat que nous
aurons cette directive est une forme de
social business act pour parler
la langage le langage le patois voilà et
ce sochaux le business as tu n'es pas
encore
transposable dans le droit français vous
avez souhaité par anticipation le faire
en tout cas ça va dans le sens de ce que
le gouvernement souhaite sur le moyen
terme le fait qu'on étende le principe
de ces marchés réservés aux acteurs de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
le gouvernement vous propose également
la sécurisation de la subvention c'est
un sujet fondamental à l'heure de la
raréfaction de la ressource publique et
de la tendance lourde à la mise en
concurrence même lorsqu'elle est
disproportionnée au regard de l'objectif
visé c'est une demande ancienne du
secteur associatif notamment de la cpca
ma collègue valérie fourneyron pourrait
en témoigner d'autant qu'elle travaille
elle a une nouvelle charte des
engagements réciproques avec le concours
du sénateur claude dilain ça fait plus
de dix ans que le monde associatif
attendait cette précision juridique sur
la subvention elle sera adoptée si vous
le souhaitez par cette louve je veux
saluer le travail effectué par la
commission des affaires sociales sur les
dispositions relatives à l'emploi sous
la houlette de votre rapporteur
christiane demontès les propositions que
vous avez fait démontre une excellente
compréhension des enjeux portés par ce
projet de loi en matière de
développement de l'emploi avec la
réintroduction de la disposition sur la
facilitation des clauses sociales vous
donner un réel coup de pouce aux
structures d'insertion grâce aux
dispositions sécurisant juridiquement
les coopératives d'activité d'emploi
vous permettait à ces dernières de se
développer sans risque et vous proposer
une alternative au statut d'auto
entrepreneur un complément au statut
d'auto entrepreneur en permettant aussi
aux cycles d'embaucher des jeunes cons
emplois d'avenir vont contribuer à
l'ambition prioritaire du gouvernement
en faveur de l'emploi des jeunes j'en
viens à présent aux dispositions qui ont
fait le plus couler d'encre celles
relatives aux cas l'une d'entre elles à
la facilitation de la reprise
d'entreprise par les salariés et avant
de vous parler du droit d'information
préalable pour les salariés qui est
introduit dans cette loi je veux là
encore est le saluer et le remercier
d'être là la présence de jean ou
ministre du travail de françois
mitterrand qui nous fait beaucoup
d'honneur
d'assister à ce débat
parce que je crois pouvoir le lui dire
humblement modestement et je dis bien
très modestement à travers cette
disposition nous essayons aussi la
majorité
et le gouvernement de nous inscrire dans
le chemin qu'il avait tracé lui même à
travers les lois que qu'il a qui porte
son nom et qui ont correspondu à un
authentique progrès social pour les
salariés dans ce pays sans que ce
progrès social et c'était magnifique de
le démontrer nous le savions mais vous
l'avez démontré monsieur le ministre que
ce progrès social soit l'adversaire de
la performance et de la croissance
économique c'est là encore ce que nous
allons essayer de tenter de réaliser à
travers cette loi alors je veux tout
d'abord dire que ces dispositions ont
naturellement leur place dans ce projet
de loi puisqu'elle vise à promouvoir
l'entrepreneuriat collectif lequel est
chiant sous la forme coopérative
je m'en suis dire qu'elle se justifie
par le fait que chaque année je leur
dirai tout au long de ce débat au moins
cinquante mille emplois disparaissent
dans des entreprises saines en bonne
santé qu'il n'y a aucune raison de
fermer au sein desquels hélas la section
du chef d'entreprise n'a pas été
préparée ou a été mal préparée en clair
des pme qui ferment parce qu aucun
repreneur ne s'est manifesté
et chacun d'entre vous dans son
territoire a été confronté à cette
réalité économique là d'une entreprise
en bonne santé dont on n'imaginait pas
qu'elle ferme et qu'ils la mettent la
clé sous la porte
m trente salariés
pour certains d'entre eux au chômage a
mené à ce que les familles quittent le
territoire parce que la reprise de cette
entreprise en bonne santé ne s'est pas
réalisé
le gouvernement ne veut pas se résigner
à cette situation que vous connaissez
nombreux sur vos territoires
nous ne nous résignons pas au gâchis de
50000 emplois détruits par an
dans un pays qui connaît le chômage de
masse réplique qui connaît les
difficultés de la crise cinquante mille
emplois détruits dans une entreprise en
bonne santé c'est un gâchis
insupportable le gouvernement est donc
déterminé à agir pour préserver ces
entreprises qui comptent tant dans la
cohésion territoriale du pays c'est
pourquoi il souhaite avec ses
dispositions permettre aux salariés de
proposer le cas échéant s'ils le
souhaitent une offre de reprise et donc
de leur donner le temps et les
informations nécessaires pour qu'il
puisse le faire moyennant évidemment des
contreparties évidentes en termes de
confidentialité ce projet de loi tout
entier réhabilite l'entrepreneuriat
collectif il n'y a donc pas de raison
valable de le combattre dans les
circonstances que j'ai décrite notre
ambition est de placer les salariés dans
la situation d'être des repreneurs
potentiels forts de leurs compétences et
de leur connaissance de l'outil de
production ni plus ni moins le droit
propriété n'est pas remis en question et
pourtant cette question a fait débat et
elle continue à faire débat dans la
société civile mais ce n'est pas le
choix du gouvernement et la liberté du
cédant est intacte il n'y a pas de
préférence accordée à l'offre des
salariés car nous avons jugé qu'il
serait difficile de définir les
conditions d'équivalence entre plusieurs
offres et que l'objectif du gouvernement
même si le débat va se poursuivre avec
vous était de faire en sorte que ce
progrès social cette mesure à fort
impact économique sur l'économie de nos
territoires c'était en sorte qu'elles
puissent passer aussi le cap du conseil
constitutionnel et de ce qui pouvait
être le thani de deux principes
fondamentaux le droit de propriété la
liberté de commerce nous débattrons de
ses aspects mais je souhaite que votre
assemblée retiennent que la volonté du
gouvernement s'exprime à la fois dans
l'ambition sociale mais aussi le
pragmatisme économique la volonté de
maintenir de l'activité dans des
territoires déjà durement touchée par la
crise nos propositions complètes
d'ailleurs le trident que nous avons
conçu pour soutenir le choc coopératif
j'en dis un mot ce trident première
flèche du trident le droit d'information
savoir que son entreprise est à vendre
et que souvent quand l'entreprise est à
vendre on est soi-même avant
avec l'unfp que ça peut avoir sur vos
vies première flèche du trident donner
le temps donc de pouvoir formuler une
offre deuxième flèche la création de la
scop d'amorçage elle limite la prise de
risque initial des salariés leur permet
de constituer une offre est une offre de
reprise s'ils le souhaitent en scop mais
la loi ne préjuge pas de la forme
juridique de la société que se choisir
lé salarié s'il se porte candidat à la
reprise de leur entreprise
cela étant dit comme c'est une loi sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire il était
légitime que le gouvernement vous
propose une formule qui facilite la
reprise en scope là où aujourd'hui le
monde des scop nous dit que pour la
transmission d'entreprise le fait de
devoir constituer un capital de plus de
50% pour les salariés c'est parfois un
obstacle à la reprise d'entreprises en
bonne santé nous avons là encore voulu
limiter ces obstacles à la reprise et
troisième flèche du trident près le
droit d'information je sais que mon
entreprise est à vendre je peux formuler
une offre la scop d'amorçage en deuxième
flash la troisième c'était le fait de
créer en lien avec bpi france et la cg
scop un fonds dead à la transmission
d'entreprise qui permettent
d'accompagner ses transmissions alors ce
trident à lui seul il ne serait pas
complet sans des mesures de formation
dead d'accompagnement qui mobiliseront à
la fois les crèches qui mobiliseront les
chambres de commerce et d'industrie qui
m'ont libye liseron les unions
régionales scop pour accompagner et
faire en sorte que les salariés ne se
censure pas eux mêmes parfois confrontés
à la crainte à la peur de devoir diriger
leur entreprise sont des questions
sérieuses il ya des amendements de
plusieurs
groupes qui ont été déposés et je veux
dire que nous serons ouverts au débat
avec vous sur les conditions
d'accompagnement de la transmission
d'entreprises mais je le redis cette
disposition est une disposition qui est
universel au sens où elle ne concerne
pas que les entreprises de l'ess est ce
qu elle a vocation à transformer des
entreprises de l'économie classique en
entreprises de l'ess est ce que je n'ai
jamais pensé moins que la scop était le
moyen de transformer du plomb en or
c'est à dire une entreprise en
difficulté soudain une entreprise
florissante
ce que je constate hélas
c'est parce qu'on ne travaille pas nous
n'avons pas collectivement travailler
sérieusement la question de la
transmission de l'entreprise ce pays
aujourd'hui accepte que de l'or des pme
qui font les résultats se transforme en
plomb parce que nous n'avons pas exploré
assez la possibilité que ces entreprises
voient leur espérance de vie dure et en
étant transmises à leurs salariés voilà
l'ambition du gouvernement à travers ce
droit l'information
vos rapporteurs marc daunis dont je veux
saluer puisqu'il est le rapporteur de ce
texte
la contribution importante est
incontestablement ce qui est déjà
l'apport de la commission affaires
économiques et gens saluent le président
daniel raoul président a visé est qui
très très avisé si je vais rajouter un
trait de ce président
donc le travail du rapporteur marc
daunis a été décisif et aussi salué le
travail de la commission des lois et du
rapporteur alain anziani qui ont
considérablement enrichi notre texte
tout en
comprenant les équilibres que nous avons
voulu trouver parce qu'il s'agit aussi
de conserver un équilibre qui respecte
les cycles de vie des pme et qui
permettent aux salariés de disposer d'un
droit nouveau
je voudrais enfin et je vais en terminer
là pardon d'avoir été un peu longue
terminez en abordant
un nombre conséquent de sujets de
modernisation relatifs aux différents
statuts mutualiste et coopératif
si les entreprises et organismes de
l'économie sociale et solidaire ont
démontré leur résilience face à la crise
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'ils se
trouvent aujourd'hui souvent confrontés
en raison de leurs caractéristiques
propres et des principes qui régissent
leurs actions à des difficultés qui
freinent leur développement face à leurs
concurrents et qui entravent le
potentiel de croissance du secteur les
modernisations et des artistes
adaptation était donc absolument
nécessaire
sans citer l'intégralité de ces mesures
je retiens que nous ferons évoluer le
statut coopératif comme il n'a jamais
évolué depuis la loi de 1947 et je veux
notamment mentionné que l'extension du
champ d'application de la révision
coopérative est une innovation majeure
parce qu'elle donnera de la force à
celles et ceux qui croient dans le
modèle coopératif et elle donnera de la
force à celles et ceux qui attendent du
modèle coopératif qu'il soit demain un
modèle alternatif d'entreprendre fort de
ses principes mais aussi fort de ces
réalisations je veux aussi souligner que
les mutuelles disposeront de nouveaux
outils financiers de développement via
les certificats mutualiste les
dispositions relatives à la coassurance
où les nouvelles unions sans dénaturer
pour autant la spécificité de la
gouvernance mutualistes je sais que le
rapporteur de la commission des finances
jean germain ya été très attentifs et
que là encore sa commission et la
commission des finances a beaucoup
travaillé pour nous aider à améliorer
ce texte le droit relatif aux
associations et fondations intègre
lui-même des avancées qui était attendue
de longue date avec la rénovation des
titres associatifs ou les dispositions
relatives aux fusions d'associations
dames et messieurs les sénateurs la loi
que j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter
poursuit donc eu plusieurs objectifs
elle définit le champ des entreprises
des structures se reconnaissant dans des
modèles de développement à partir des
principes qui ont guidé l'action et les
finalités elle affirme l'engagement de
l'état en faveur de la promotion de la
valorisation de l'organisation du
soutien et du développement de le ss ces
dispositions visent à organiser à
planifier l'action des services de
l'état en lien avec les collectivités
territoriales
elle détermine enfin les modalités de
représentation de ce secteur auprès des
pouvoirs publics c'est la première fois
qu'une loi décline ses ambitions au
service d'une économie qui se veut tout
entière dédiée au service de l'homme je
nous souhaite de fructueux débat et je
conclurai en paraphrasant le célèbre
écrivain anglais george bernard shaw
socialiste par ailleurs dans la vie
huile disait il ya deux catégories
d'individus ce qui regarde le monde
disait-il mais là je dirai ce qui
regarde l'économie telle qu'elle est se
demande pourquoi ceux qui imaginent
l'économie telle qu'elle devrait être et
se disent pourquoi pas
dans la discussion générale
la parole est maintenant monsieur marc
daunis rapporteur de la commission des
affaires économiques
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la commission des affaires économiques
présentes à l'examen du sénat le texte
qu'elle a adopté le 16 octobre dernier
sur le projet de loi relatifs à
l'économie sociale et solidaire
rapporte eurofonds intervenants notre
commission je m'astreins de ré dans
cette présentation a jugulé ma passion
naturel pour l'économie et
particulièrement pour l'économie sociale
et solidaire
pourront rester autant coutumier qui
sied à cette fonction de rapporteur
l'économie sociale et solidaire n'est
pas une idée neuve veut bien qu'elle
soit d'avenir est prometteuse et dès les
années 10 ans 40 des titres anglais se
sont rendu compte qu'ils pouvaient en se
réunissant
se fournir à moindre coût et gagner leur
indépendance
c'est en partant ainsi des besoins de
chacun que l'économie sociale et
solidaire a peu à peu élaborés par des
voies diverses certaines des réponses
qui sont aujourd'hui au coeur de notre
économie et de notre société
protection sociale production agricole
grande distribution action sanitaire et
sociale
et l'économie sociale et solidaire est
toujours à l'avant garde de secteurs
tels que la gestion des déchets qui
seront le moteur d'une économie de
menditte circulaire il s'agit donc
d'une attitude pragmatique qui par la
coopération ou la mutualisation
recherchent la solution la plus efficace
et la plus équitable pour ses membres or
cette solution ne passe pas forcément
par le modèle de l'entreprise
capitalistique qui sépare par nature les
apporteurs de capitaux de ceux qui par
leur force de travail participent plus
directement la production
la crise financière l'a bien montré
j'allais dire démontrez
l'entreprise capitalistique et son
corollaire
l'intermédiation financière
ne constitue pas le seul modèle pour
réaliser un projet entrepreneurial
les entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire ne relève pas pour autant de
l'assistanat
elle cherche l'équilibré économique et
sont parfois thomas auteur efficace ou
plus efficaces que d'autres entreprises
en effet au lieu de consacrer leurs
bénéfices à la rémunération
d'intermédiaires tels que les apporteurs
de capitaux elles les utilisent autant
que possible pour remplir leur objet
social que celui ci soit la production
ouvrière l'assurance de risque ou l'aide
à des personnes dites défavorisées
il ne s'agit pas monsieur le ministre a
rappelé d'opposer les deux modèles
l'économie sociale et solidaire ne se
substitue pas à l'économie
capitalistique même si elle est capable
de la côtoyer efficacement dans certains
secteurs mais elle apportera de plus en
plus souvent une réponse originale dans
les domaines où le modèle capitalistique
ne trouve pas de rentabilité suffisante
ou ne correspond plus ou pas aux
aspirations profondes de nos possibles
concitoyens voire aux enjeux humains
économiques sociaux environnementaux
auxquels sont confrontés notre planète
nos sociétés bref à l'évolution de ce
monde le présent projet de loi a d'abord
pour ambition d'apporter une visibilité
un secteur par essence divers mais
proche des territoires car 75% des lieux
de décision des coopératives
75% sont situés en région alors que 90%
des premières entreprises françaises ont
leur siège en ile de france
il lui permettra de franchir une
nouvelle étape de 2001 à 2009 le taux de
croissance de l'emploi a été de
2,7 pour cent pour les entreprises qui
ont choisi ce mode d'entreprendre contre
1,1 pour cent dans les autres
entreprises du secteur privé je me
réjouis que le gouvernement ait décidé
de soumettre cette loi en premier lieu à
notre assemblée que monsieur le ministre
me permette de l'en remercier le travail
effectué par notre commission des
affaires économiques mais aussi par les
trois commissions qui se sont saisies
pour avis montre l'intérêt du cdh a pour
ce texte malgré un calendrier
parlementaire
particulièrement chargé ce texte n'a pas
été écrit dans le secret de cabinets
d'administrations il résulte d'une
longue concertation avec l'ensemble des
acteurs et il faut le saluer monsieur le
ministre
salue et votre engagement personnel sur
ce texte c'est un texte vous l'avez dit
un texte d'équilibré que vous avez
présenté le 24 juillet dernier qui
concilie une vision d'ensemble avec des
réponses concrètes pour chacune des
grandes familles de l'économie sociale
et solidaire le projet de loi définit
d'abord pour la première fois
à dire elle était temps
le périmètre de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et il retient dans son article
1er une approche inclusive
cette approche inclusive n'allait pas de
soi dans l'attachement peut être fort
chez
nombreux acteurs de l'économie sociale
et solidaire à des statuts qui par
ailleurs ont fait certaines preuves en
la matière au delà des coopératives des
associations des mutuelles et fondations
le champ de l'économie sociale et
solidaire comprendra donc officiellement
des sociétés qui partageait inscrivent
dans leur statut
j'assiste inscrits dans leur statut les
grands principes de lucrativité limitée
de participation d'un partage habilités
des réserves car l'économie sociale et
solidaire se définit d'abord comme une
certaine manière d'entreprendre plus que
comme un statut ou un secteur d'activité
donné elle a vocation à porter son
regard sur un domaine de plus en plus
vaste de l'économie
la commission a approuvé cette ouverture
elle préserve en effet le respect des
grands principes et permet de diffuser
dans l'économie les principes de
l'économie sociale et solidaire en
direction des entrepreneurs qui ne sont
pas forcément prêts adopté d'emblée des
statuts plus contraignant et cela pour
leur montrer tout l'intérêt que
peut-être représenteront ses statuts
pour leur activité le texte définit dans
son article de l'utilité sociale
requises aussi bien des sociétés
commerciales admise dans l'économie
sociale et solidaire que de celles qui
demandent un agrément entreprises
solidaires la commission a procédé à une
réécriture de cet article avec un souci
de clarification
elle a aussi instauré une déclaration de
principe que je m'étais permis de lui
suggérer pour laquelle les entreprises
volontaires pourront signaler leur
volonté et j'assiste c'est un acte
volontaire
pour ces entreprises de remplir des
engagements notamment en matière sociale
qui vont au delà des principes
fondamentaux de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
le projet de loi constate également
l'existence de grandes institutions
transversale de ss conseil supérieur
chambre régionale et conseil national
dans son volet territorial
il favorise le lien avec l'économie
classique au travers des pôles
territoriaux de coopération économique
et le projet de loi prévoit la prise en
compte de le ss dans les contrats de
développement
territoriaux de développement
territorial pardon menée dans le grand
paris la commission a étendu cette
mesure aux schémas régionaux de
développement économique à l'article 7
le projet de loi réforme l'agrément
entreprises solidaires tels que cela a
été rappelé précédemment par monsieur le
ministre
les dispositions actuelles
insuffisamment précises font l'objet
d'interprétations diverses selon les
régions la commission a complété la
règle prévue par le texte en matière d
celle des rémunérations au sein de
l'entreprise
le projet de loi définit dans son
article 10 la notion de subventions
cette notion est aujourd'hui
essentiellement jurisprudentielle ce qui
est source d'insécurité juridique
souvent les administrations locales
préfèrent recourir à la procédure lourde
du marché public alors que la subvention
aurait permis d'atteindre le même
objectif plus rapidement plus souplement
la commission a complété ce titre
premier en prévoyant cohérence avec les
évolutions du droit européen la
possibilité de passer des marchés
réservés à des organismes employant des
personnes handicapés ou défavorisés et l
inscrire dans la loi le dispositif local
d'accompagnement qui dans bien des
endroits est un instrument puissant de
développement de l'économie sociale et
solidaire dans les territoires
sur proposition c'est votre serviteur la
commission a aussi proposé une
définition de la notion d'innovation
sociale cela a été rappelé par monsieur
le ministre je n'y reviens pas
alors le fameux titre 2
ce titre 2 a bénéficié d'une certaine
médiatisation
qui en a souvent peu car up caricaturer
les enjeux
les articles 11 et 12 instaure
simplement une obligation d'information
des salariés avant la cession d'une
entreprise afin de leur permettre de
présenter une offre de reprise
la reprise d'une entreprise par les
salariés
demeure l'un des meilleurs moyens de
préserver l'emploi
de transmettre les talents et de
poursuivre le projet entreprenariale
on nous a dit que le délai de deux mois
était insuffisant
c'est pour cela que je me suis
permettent de permis pardon de proposer
d'instaurer un dispositif souple simple
d'information des salariés j'ai à dire
tout au long de la vie de l'entreprise
au sujet des possibilités de reprises
des modalités afférentes à ces
possibilités de reprise ce dispositif a
été inscrit à l'article 11 à
je le répète dispositif léger pour les
entreprises et calanques qui ambitionne
de contribuer à faire émerger sur le
long terme les vocations et les
compétences parmi les salariés car les
études le montrent le chef d'entreprise
mais aussi les salariés eux mêmes ne
pense pas souvent à cette possibilité ou
bien elle ne leur apparaît que de
manière
trop abstraite sans qu'il en aperçoive
toujours les avantages mais
éventuellement aussi les limites et les
difficultés
malgré cela le dispositif des articles
11 et 12 a été source d'incompréhension
certains l'ont présenté comme une menace
grave sur les transmissions
d'entreprises voire une atteinte au
droit de propriété en fait
nous avons aussi travaillé
pour qu'il présente les garanties fortes
en termes de confidentialité et qu'ils
élargissent leur offre des possibilités
offertes aux chefs d'entreprise pour la
transmission d'un travail qui a été fait
et différents amendements concourt à ce
souci à sécuriser tout ce dispositif qui
demeure au combien quand on est
conscient des enjeux importants pour le
nombre d'emplois qui sont détruits
chaque année tout le monde s'entend à
peu près tout le monde de bonne foi à
reconnaître qu'il est de l'ordre de 50
mille emplois détruits par an
le texte comprend ensuite des
dispositions à destination de chacune
des familles de l'économie sociale et
solidaire tout particulièrement les
coopératives mais aussi le monde
mutualiste les associations les
fondations coopérative volet majeur du
texte est vrai qu'elles représentent
plus de 70% du chiffre global du secteur
de l'économie sociale 2 du chiffre
d'affaires global du secteur de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
mouvement coopératif français un des
plus importants du monde avec 21 de 1000
entreprises coopératives qui emploie
directement et indirectement près d'un
million de personnes dans notre pays une
personne sur deux est d'ailleurs membre
d'une ou de plusieurs coopératives
les coopératives constitue bien cet
atout pour le redressement économique
véritable pilier
de l'économie sociale et solidaire pour
reprendre le titre du rapport nous
avions commis
avec notre collègue marie noëlle
lienemann qui en était
rapporteur en 2012 issu du groupe de
travail que je présidais rapport dans
sont d'ailleurs issus bon nombre des
dispositions du projet de loi je vous
sais gré monsieur le ministre de l'avoir
autant pris en considération votre texte
vise à conforter le développement du
secteur coopératif à la fois en
modernisant les statuts et en
assouplissant les règles régissant le
fonctionnement de ces entreprises la
définition de l'entreprise coopérative
et réaffirmer à l'article 13
par le rappel et l'actualisation des
principes fondateurs notre commission il
ya intégré d'autres principes
coopératifs reconnu au niveau
international afin de bien marquer la
loi de la spécificité de ce type
d'entreprise ils sont que nous soyons
parvenus à un bon équilibre sur cet
article à l'article 14
le projet de loi réforme est généraliste
ou les a toutes les familles la
procédure dite de révision coopérative
il sera possible éventuellement d'aller
plus loin encore en permettant
d'assister les entreprises dans leur
mise en oeuvre le texte en précisément à
développer les sociétés coopératives de
production les scop et monsieur le
ministre l'a rappelé avec la création
article 15 un statut de scop d'amorçage
quand l'article 17 autre point important
pour les coopératives autorise la
constitution de groupements de scop
l'idée de favoriser la création de
grande union où les salariés d'une scop
seraient également associés d'autres
scop là aussi il sera possible de faire
évoluer le texte
en permettant à des scop détenant des
filiales le sous forme de sociétés de
les transformer à leur tour en scope
sans pour autant en perdre le contrôle
dans un même esprit à l'article 29 la
commission a permis aux entreprises
artisanales regrouper en coopérative de
réaliser des politiques commerciales
communes pouvant passer par
l'établissement de prix commun le projet
de loi comporte par ailleurs les
sociétés coopératives d'intérêt
collectif aux articles 21 et 22 je passe
plus le texte autorise pardonnez-moi
notamment les collectivités à et détenir
jusqu'à 50% du capital contre 20%
aujourd'hui afin de les pérenniser et de
les dynamiser
je passe plus rapidement sur les
dispositions relatives aux coopératives
en soulignant toutefois qu'il traite ce
texte une majorité des familles
existantes s'agissant des dernières
dispositions du texte le titre iv
comprendre des dispositions relatives à
la famille des mutuelles il avait ainsi
aux articles 34 et 35 des verrous
juridiques qui rendent aujourd'hui peu
difficile la conclusion de contrats de
coassurance entre des mutuelles des
assurances et des institutions de
prévoyance ainsi que des contrats
collectifs d'une manière générale ce
type de contrat est appelé à se
développer avec la généralisation de
l'assurance complémentaire dans les
entreprises il institue aussi à
l'article 36 des certificats mutualiste
et des titres paritaire les titres 5 et
6 concernent respectivement les
associations et les fondations titre
associatif qui a rencontré peu de succès
depuis sa création il faut le
reconnaître et réforme est étendue aux
fondations le titre 7 ne comprend qu'une
disposition à l'article 49 il favorise
le recours aux entreprises solidaires
parmi les éco organismes ces entreprises
trouvent un champ d'action qui est
particulièrement approprié cette
disposition elle aussi a fait l'objet
d'une présentation des formes et
j'insiste elle ne se présente pas comme
ne représente pas une menace pour
l'emploi puisqu'elle favorise au
contraire des entreprises qui sont
créatrices d'emplois tout
particulièrement d'emploi local
enfin le titre 8 comprend des
dispositions diverses finales concernant
notamment la mise en oeuvre de
l'agrément entreprises solidaires
d'utilité sociale et de l'obligation
d'information
mes chers collègues c'est un texte
enrichi que vous propose la commission
des affaires économiques sans
bouleverser les équilibres obtenus au
cours de la remarquable concertation qui
a suivi toute l'élaboration de ce texte
j'espère que nos débats permettront de
faire avancer l'idée selon laquelle
l'économie sociale et solidaire
ni un bouleversement redoutable n'est
une pratique utopique est marginal c'est
un secteur porteur non seulement
d'emploi et de développement mais d'un
emploi et d'un développement plus riches
de sens et pour les producteurs comme
pour les consommateurs c'est à dire pour
nos concitoyens il a été rappelé la
nécessité de développer
une économie au service de l'humain est
un humain qui soit au coeur de
l'économie
monsieur le ministre le dialogue a été
franc et fructueux il se poursuit avec m
mais vous le savez le parlement jouera
son rôle de législateur et lors de ces
débats et nous poursuivrons cet échange
extrêmement fructueux que nous avons eu
jusqu'à présent
permettez-moi en conclusion de remercier
les rapporteur pour avis chaque sénateur
aussi pour la qualité du travail que
nous avons effectué ensemble quel
travail que j'espère a été efficace et
pourra contribuer à des débats qui
seront le plus clair et surtout les plus
prometteurs pour tout ce secteur qui
demande notre connaissance et notre
soutien merci
dans la discussion générale la parole
est maintenant madame christiane
demontès rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des affaires sociales
le seul président monsieur le ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
je le dis marquera l'histoire de
l'économie sociale et solidaire dans
notre pays car c'est la première fois
qu'une loi lui est consacré la
commission des affaires sociales a donc
souhaité donner un avis sur ce projet de
loi compte tenu de la densité de ce
texte comme l'ont rappelé à l'instant
monsieur le ministre et notre collègue
rapporteur marc daunis au niveau de la
commission des affaires sociales nous
avons restera notre avis aux articles
ayant un lien direct ou indirect avec le
code du travail soit une dizaine
d'articles au total la commission des
affaires sociales a adopté la vingtaine
d'amendements que je lui ai présenté le
15 octobre dernier
presque tous ont été adoptés le
lendemain dans le texte de la commission
des affaires économiques je voudrais
rapidement vous présenter les principaux
d'entre eux d'abord à l'article 7 nous
avons ajouté les acteurs du logement et
de l'hébergement des personnes
défavorisées parmi les bénéficiaires de
plein droit du nouvel agrément
entreprises solidaires d'utilité sociale
nous avons également porté à l'article
52 de un à deux ans la période minimale
pendant laquelle les entreprises
bénéficiant de l'agrément solidaires
seront réputés bénéficier de plein droit
du nouvel agrément ce délai
supplémentaire permettra aux entités
concernées de s'approprier les
dispositions de la nouvelle loi et de
modifier leur statut sont convoquer une
assemblée générale extraordinaire
à l'article nov nous avons rendu
obligatoire la conclusion de conventions
dans toutes les régions entre les
préfets d'une passe de là les
représentants de l'état
et les maisons de l'emploi et les
gestionnaires des plans locaux pour
l'insertion et l'emploi d'autre part
afin de favoriser le recours aux clauses
sociales ces conventions permettront de
repérer les marchés pertinents et les
publics à insérer de guider la rédaction
des clauses d'insertion est
d'accompagner les entreprises titulaires
des lots dans la mise en oeuvre des
clauses sociales la généralisation de
ces conventions présente un double
intérêt elle relancera le recours aux
clauses sociales dans les marchés
publics de l'état qui en ont bien besoin
qui accuse un retard certain en la
matière et elle fournira un cadre sur la
base du volontariat aux grandes
collectivités territoriales qui devront
mettre en place les schémas de promotion
des achats publics socialement
responsable prévu justement à l'article
9 nous avons enfin souhaité sécuriser
les dispositions de l'article 33
articles importants puisque relatifs aux
entrepreneurs salariés associés des
coopératives d'activités et d'emploi les
céréales celle-ci né au milieu des
années 1990 pour permettre à des
porteurs de projet de créer et
développer leurs activités dans un cadre
coopératif
autonome et sécurisée
ces coopératives emplissent deux grandes
missions elle accompagne les enfants les
entrepreneurs dans la définition et
l'accompagnement de leur projet et elle
met à leur disposition des services
mutualisés qui comprennent notamment la
gestion financière la gestion sociale et
la gestion administrative
elle offre donc une vraie alternative à
l'auto entreprenariat au couveuse
d'activités ou aux sociétés de portage
salarial
selon la confédération générale des scop
on comptait au 31 décembre 2012 91
entreprises autonomes et 44
établissements secondaires qui
rassemblait 5000 salariés leur nombre
augmentant de 15 à 20% par an il s'est
toutefois avéré que les critères
classiques du contrat de travail ne
convenait pas aux spécificités de ces
coopérative compte tenu de l'absence de
lien de subordination entre les
direction et des entrepreneurs et les
modalités et des modalités de calcul de
la rémunération fondée sur le chiffre
d'affaires réalisé par ces derniers
c'est pourquoi l'article 33 créer un
nouveau contrat dans le code du travail
distingue du contrat de travail de droit
commun au profit des entrepreneurs
salariés associés des coopératives
d'activités et d'emploi par souci de
lisibilité nous avons clairement
distinguer les règles du contrat des
entrepreneurs salariés associés est
celle applicable aux entrepreneurs
salariés qui ne sont pas encore devenus
associés de la coopérative à l'issue de
la période de test de 36 mois de leurs
projets
compte tenu du principe d'assimilation
présenté à l'article l 73 31 du code du
travail nous avons également supprimé
les dispositions redondantes pour éviter
tout risque d'interprétation
a contrario le développement de ces
coopératives originale pourrait
entraîner toujours selon la
confédération générale des scop plus de
dix mille créations nettes d'emplois
dans les cinq années à venir avec un
cadre juridique ainsi sécurisé nous
donnons tous les moyens à ces
coopératives pour se développer trois
amendements votés par la commission des
affaires sociales n'ont pas été adoptées
dans le texte de la commission des
affaires économiques compte tenu de
l'importance qu'il revêt à mes yeux je
les ai présenté à nouveau mercredi
dernier lors de la commission des
affaires sociales moyennant quelques
adaptations et la commission les a
adoptées je voudrais les évoquer si vous
le permettez brièvement le premier
amendement concerne la fourchette de
rémunération des entreprises qui
demandent à bénéficier du nouvel
agrément solidaire prévu à l'article 7
le texte de la commission prévoit que la
moyenne des sommes versées aux cinq
salariés les mieux rémunérés ou
dirigeants les mieux rémunérés doit être
inférieur à un plafond fixé à sept fois
la rémunération annuelle d'un salarié à
temps plein qui perçoit le smig où le
salaire minimum de branche si celui ci
est supérieur
nous avons souhaité maintenir cette
disposition
mais en remplaçant la référence au
salaire minimum par la moyenne des cinq
rémunérations les puf les plus faibles
dans l'entité considéré nous avons ainsi
souhaité rendre le dispositif plus
dynamique et vertueux d'une part en
renforçant l'activé l'attractivité du
secteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire pour certains profils
techniques très recherchée et d'autre
part en essayant de tirer vers le haut
les salaires les plus faibles dans
l'antre dans l'entité considérer afin de
lutter contre ce qu'on appelle les
trappes à pauvreté alors je sais que
nous aurons le débat en séance monsieur
le ministre on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler au moment de la présentation de
la maman parce que nous sommes aussi
plus fort quand on quand nous
réfléchissons et quand nous prenons des
décisions collectivement le second
amendement concerne l'information
préalable des salariés prévue à
l'article 11 monsieur le ministre comme
monsieur le rapporteur au fond en m'ont
parlé il s'agit de pour cet article 11
du projet de loi de la transmission de
ce qu'on appelle la transmission
d'entreprise et le droit d'information
des salariés je rappelle d'ailleurs que
cet article 11 concerne bien toutes les
entreprises et pas seulement celle de
l'économie sociale et solidaire le texte
actuel ne prévoit pas de délai précis
pour l'information préalable des
salariés en cas de cession d'un fonds de
commerce dans les entreprises employant
entre 50 et 249 salariés nous avons
souhaité par souci d'efficacité et de
simplicité
instaurer un délai de deux mois en cas
de carence du comité d'entreprise dans
ces entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
coïncidant avec une absence des délégués
du personnel en reprenant ainsi la règle
prévue dans les entreprises employant
moins de 50 salariés les étude de la
dares la direction de l'animation de la
recherche des études et des statistiques
montre en effet qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une hypothèse d'école puisque selon
une publication daté d'avril 2013
6 % des établissements de plus de 50
salariés ne disposaient d'aucune
institutions représentatives du
personnel en 2010 1011 nous avons
également adopté un amendement similaire
à l'article 12 concernant les cas de
cession des parts sociales actions ou
valeurs mobilières
donnant accès à la majorité du capital
dans les entreprises employant entre 50
et 249 salariés enfin outre ces trois
amendements la commission des affaires
sociales a adopté un amendement à
l'article 33 afin de poursuivre la
sécurisation du dispositif en précisant
notamment que tous les entrepreneurs
salariés qu'il soit ou non associé
jouissent des mêmes droits et sont
soumis aux mêmes suggestions et qu'ils
doivent être affiliés aux assurances
sociales du régime général voilà
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues le fruit des travaux de
la commission des affaires sociales nous
aurons bien évidemment l'occasion au
cours de notre débat d'aborder l'été des
questions qui dépasse le strict cadre de
l'avis de la commission mais auquel nous
attachons personnellement une grande
importance je pense par exemple à la
place des structures d'insertion par
l'activité économique dans le projet de
loi ou encore à la définition de
l'utilité sociale et de l'innovation
sociale sur tous ces sujets vos
explications et précisions monsieur le
ministre sont attendus et permettront de
répondre à certaines de nos
interrogations mais surtout à certaines
interrogations des personnes que nous
avons pu auditionner qui sont
particulièrement concernés
pour terminer je voudrais rappeler les
mots empreints de sagesse de léon
bourgeois léon bourgeois prix nobel de
la paix et ancien sénateur extrait de
son ouvrage la solidarité la loi de
solidarité des actions individuelles je
cite finit par apparaître entre les
hommes non comme une nécessité
extérieurement et arbitrairement imposé
mais comme une loi d'organisation
intérieur à la vie est un moyen de
libération je souhaite que le
développement des associations des
fondations des mutuelles des
coopératives et des sociétés
commerciales qui sont dans le champ de
l'économie sociale et solidaire ou qui
aspirent à y entre ayant trait
permettent de promouvoir ces valeurs
humanisme humaniste pardon la solidarité
la démocratie participative qui sont
parfois il faut bien le dire mise à mal
dans notre société tel est l'objectif de
ce projet de loi que je partage et je
soutiens avec enthousiasme je vous
remercie
dans la discussion générale la parole
est maintenant monsieur jean germain
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des finances
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
madame
et messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues
le projet de loi relatifs l'économie
sociale et solidaire a pour ambition
d'encourager un changement d'échelle de
l'économie sociale et solidaire dans
tous ses aspects
afin de construire avec les entreprises
de l'économie sociale et solidaire une
stratégie de croissance plus robuste
plus riche en emplois plus durables
et plus juste socialement
pour cela la question du financement des
organismes
composant le secteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire est fondamentale
le présent projet de loi crée ou
rénovent des dispositifs destinés à
renforcer les capitaux propres des
organismes d'assurance mutualiste et
paritaire des associations et des
fondations
la commission des finances a souhaité
limiter le champ de sa saisine à ces
dispositions qui relèvent clairement de
sa compétence
cela concerne en premier lieu les
dispositions relatives aux sociétés
d'assurance
aux mutuelles et aux institutions de
prévoyance
ces organismes sont des sociétés de
personnes
sans capital social
leurs fonds propres
résulte non du capital versé par des
actionnaires mais de la mise en réserve
de leurs résultats
ce principe fondamental du mutualisme et
du paritarisme
présente l'inconvénient
de fermer l'accès aux marchés de
capitaux pour le renforcement de ses
fonds propres
seuls des titres de dettes sous des
formes variées peuvent être émis par ces
organismes
cette restriction n'a pas empêché
jusqu'ici le développement des acteurs
mutualistes et paritaire dans le secteur
de l'assurance
au sein duquel ils occupent une place
majeure
53% du marché de l'assurance automobile
50% ce de celui de l'assurance
habitation et l'essentiel des
complémentaires santé
le monde mutualiste et paritaire a même
fait preuve d'une remarquable résilience
durant la crise financière qui a
profondément ébranlé certaines des
sociétés de structures capitalistes
classique que l'on présentait pourtant
comme les mieux adaptés à une économie
de plus en plus financiarisé
on observe cependant un double mouvement
qui pourrait placer certains de ces
organismes dans une situation difficile
d'une part l'accroissement de la
concurrence sur le marché de l'assurance
qui conduit à une réduction des marges
et donc de la possibilité
d'accumuler des bénéfices
d'autre part le renforcement des
exigences de solvabilité imposées aux
assureurs en particulier la directive
européenne solvabilité 2 dont on peut
d'ailleurs se demander si elle tient
suffisamment compte des spécificités et
des points forts du modèle mutualiste
ces règles obligent les assureurs à
disposer de plus de fonds propres pour
assurer la couverture de leurs
engagements et impose une définition de
plus en plus restrictive des instruments
de financement
admis dans la catégorie des fonds
propres de meilleure qualité
il ne faut pas que ce souci légitime de
garantir la solidité des assureurs
conduisent indirectement
imposé comme standard la société de
capitaux au détriment du modèle
mutualiste qui lui a justement fait la
preuve de sa robustesse
c'est là qu'intervient le présent projet
de loi qui prévoit la création de titres
spécifique
dénommée certificat mutualistes
s'ils sont émis par des sociétés
d'assurances mutuelles qui relèvent du
code des assurances ou par des mutuelles
qui relèvent du code de la mutualité et
certificats paritaire s'ils sont émis
par des institutions de prévoyance qui
relèvent du code de la sécurité sociale
le régime de ces certificats répond à
une triple contrainte premièrement le
respect des principes mutualistes
deuxièmement la satisfaction des
critères prudentiels permettant de
classer les fonds recueillis parmi les 4
me les capitaux propres de la meilleure
qualité troisièmement la protection des
épargnants
s'agissant du respect des principes
mutualistes
je souligne que les certificats ne donne
ni droits de vote supplémentaires en
assemblée générale ni droits sur l'actif
net de l'émetteur les organismes
mutualistes se sont développées sur un
fondement affinitaire qui concerne
aujourd'hui toute sa force et constitue
l'un des moteurs essentiels de leurs
actions le dispositif proposé permet de
préserver cette spécificité si précieuse
le périmètre des souscripteurs des
certificats est ainsi restreint aux
personnes liées par une affection
societatis direct ou indirect avec
l'émetteur la commission des finances
adoptée sur ce point un amendement
d'harmonisation entre les différents
types de certificats
amendement intégrés par la commission
des affaires économiques dans le texte
qui vous est soumis
enfin comme la logique de souscription
doit avant d'être économique
répondre à la volonté du souscripteur de
soutenir l'action et le développement de
l'organisme auquel il est lié la
rémunération des certificats est
plafonné à une fraction des résultats de
l'émetteur
s'agissant de l'aspect prudentielles
tous les fonds propres ne sont pas logés
à la même enseigne pour pouvoir être
comptés intégralement pour la couverture
des engagements de l'assureur les fonds
doivent présenter certaines
caractéristiques tenant à leur
permanence à leur capacité à absorber
les pertes enregistrées par l'émetteur
et à la flexibilité de leur rémunération
c'est le cas des certificats la
rémunération est fixée dit screen
discrétionnairement et chaque année par
l'assemblée générale de l'émetteur ils
sont susceptibles d'absorber les pertes
de l'émetteur il n'y a pas de
remboursement possible sauf liquidation
de l'émetteur et seulement après
désintéressement de l'ensemble des
créanciers les rachats sont mis en place
de manière facultative par l'émetteur de
manière contingenté est sous le contrôle
de l'autorité de contrôle prudentiel et
de résolution
le projet de loi définit un ordre de
priorité sur lequel la commission des
finances a proposé un amendement
d'harmonisation lui aussi adopté par la
commission des affaires économiques
s'agissant enfin de la protection de
l'épargnant le présent projet de loi
renvoie aux obligations d'information et
de conseil déjà prévues pour certaines
opérations de capitalisation organisé
par le code des assurances et le code de
la sécurité sociale la commission des
finances a adopté un amendement visant à
clarifier compléter ces obligations qui
a été intégrée au texte établi par la
commission des affaires économiques il
me semble qu'avec ces amendements le
dispositif proposé est équilibré
étant entendu que la souscription de ces
titres tu ouvres trouve sa justification
dans la volonté de soutenir l'émetteur
est d'accompagner son développement
la commission des finances a ainsi émis
un avis favorable à l'adoption de
l'article 36
parmi les dispositions relatives aux
organismes d'assurance j'ai également
souhaité examiner celles qui tendent à
favoriser le développement de la
coassurance en matière d'assurance de
personnes
en effet dans ce domaine
interviennent des organismes d'assurance
régie par des corpus de règles
différents l'objet de l'article 34 du
présent projet de loi est de permettre
la réalisation de telles opérations pour
cela il procède à une mise en cohérence
des dispositions des trois codes
assurances mutualité sécurité sociale il
faut souligner que l'alignement se
réalise sur les dispositions les plus
protectrices des assurés cette
harmonisation est particulièrement
nécessaire aux mutuelles dont la taille
et le champ géographique ne
correspondent pas toujours à l'ampleur
des contrats de branche là encore le
dispositif proposé veille au respect des
principes de gouvernance propre au
secteur mutualiste va nous reste à ce
que le respect des principes de
gouvernance propre secteur mutualiste
soit préservé les salariés couverts par
de tels contrats bénéficient du statut
de sociétaires et d'adhérents de chacune
des sociétés d'assurances mutuelles et
mutuelles participant à l'opération de
coassurance je considère donc que le
dispositif proposé constitue un progrès
et la commission des finances a approuvé
cet article
l'autre volet de la saisine de la
commission des finances concerne le
financement au sens large des
associations des fondations et des fonds
de dotation regroupés au ti au sein des
titres 5 et 6 de ce projet de loi là
encore il s'agit d'un sujet de grande
importance comme le souligne l'étude
d'impact annexée au projet de loi
la france a un vivier de plus d'un
million d'associations qui compte plus
de 21 millions d'adhérents et environ 13
millions de bénévoles en termes d'emploi
comme le rappelle l'étude d'impact
d'impact annexée au présent projet de
loi l'effectif salarié total les
associations s'élèvent à près de 1,8
million de personnes soit un peu moins
de 80 % du total de l'économie sociale
et solidaire
notre capacité à conforter le modèle
associatif et à renforcer les canaux de
financement des associations
représentent donc un véritable enjeu y
compris économique qu'ont notre pays tel
est l'objet de l'article 40 de ce projet
de loi relatif à la réforme des titres
associatifs
comme vous le savez les associations
sont autorisées à émettre des
obligations depuis
1985 certaines d'entre elles dénommé
titre associatif présente la
particularité de n'être remboursables
qu'à la seule initiative de l'émetteur
ce sont donc des quasi fonds propres en
outre quand il n'est pas fait appel
public à l'épargné les obligations
émises par les associations sont
rémunérés à un taux plafonné qui est la
somme du taux moyen du marché
obligataire petit hameau du trimestre
précédent et d'une rémunération définies
par arrêté du ministre chargé de
l'économie laquelle ne peut excéder
trois points cependant les associations
ne font aujourd'hui que peu usage de ces
titres qui restent par ailleurs mal
connue des investisseurs
l'article 40 espère donner un nouveau
souffle à ce mode de financement en
faisant des titres associatif les
instruments plus conformes aux pratiques
du marché à cette fin il est proposé de
mieux borné l'horizon de remboursement
des titres associatif en permettant que
les contrats d'émission de titres
associatif puis ceux stipulés que le
remboursement aura lieu à une échéance
déterminée d'au moins 7 ans dès lors que
les excédents constitué depuis
l'émission déduction fait des éventuels
déficits constitués durant la même
période dépasse le montant nominal de
l'émission
de plus ces nouveaux titres à durée
déterminée pourront faire bénéficier
leurs souscripteurs d'une rémunération
additionnelle à définir par arrêté dans
la limite de 2 5% ainsi le taux maximal
de ses dernières opérations pour s
établir la tm au plus 5 % soit dans les
conditions actuelles le taux de 7,30 %
la commission des finances exprimé son
accord sur ce système tout en adoptant
un amendement destiné à renforcer
l'encadrement des émissions lequel a été
intégré dans le texte de la commission
des affaires économiques la commission a
également donné son accord à l'article
47 du projet de loi qui donne aux
fondations le droit d'émettre de tels
titres de même elle a approuvé l'article
46 relatifs aux fondations d'entreprises
qui permettra aux mandataires sociaux
sociétaires adhérents aux actionnaires
de l'entreprise fondatrice d'effectuer
des dons à ces structures à l'instar de
leurs salariés
enfin l'article 48 propose une légère
modification des conditions de création
des fonds de dotation qui sont des
structures issues de la loi de
modernisation de l'économie de 2008
comme vous le savez ces outils se
caractérisent par leur grande simplicité
de fonctionnement par rapport aux
traditionnels fondation reconnue
d'utilité publique
sans remettre en cause cet atout cet
article vise à éviter que ne se
multiplient des fonds dormants en
proposant d'instaurer une dotation
plancher au moment de la création d'un
fonds dont le montant serait fixé par
décret l'étude d'impact précise que le
montant de 25000 euros est envisagée par
le gouvernement
la commission a soutenu cette démarche
moyennant l'adoption d'un amendement
destiné à mieux encadrer le pouvoir
réglementaire amendement là aussi
intégrés dans le texte de la commission
des affaires économiques avant de
terminer un mot sur les articles 41 et
42 du projet de loi il s'agit cette fois
de définir le droit applicable en cas de
fusion ou de scission
d'associations
l'inscription de telles dispositions
dans ce texte est une initiative très
heureuse du gouvernement car le vide
juridique actuel pénalise fortement la
rationalisation du paysage associatif et
les rapprochements d'association en
termes fiscaux qui intéresse au premier
chef la commission des finances il n'y a
pas de dispositions normatives dans ce
texte pourtant selon les éléments
recueillis auprès de bercy
les articles 41 et 42 auront des
conséquences fiscales la définition du
régime des fusions étant une condition
sinequanone pour que l'administration
fiscale soit en mesure de préciser que
le régime de sueur d'imposition et les
droits de mutation forfaitaire
applicable aux fusions de sociétés
s'applique également à ces opérations il
s'agira donc de veiller à ce que la
direction de la législation fiscale
s'empare bien du sujet après la
promulgation de la loi sur la base de
ces éléments la commission des finances
a approuvé l'adoption de ces articles au
bout du compte monsieur le ministre je
suis heureux de pouvoir vous dire que la
commission des finances a exprimé un
avis favorable à l'adoption par le sénat
de ce projet de loi très riche je vous
remercie de votre attention
dans la discussion générale la parole
d'un maintenant à monsieur alain anziani
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des lois
se de ministres
du président présente monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
beaucoup de choses ont été dites donc je
ne vais pas les répéter mais je note que
finalement sur tous les bancs
chacun aujourd'hui a conscience des
limites moi j'appellerai de l'économie
traditionnelle
et au fond nous avons tous appris
que même dans une période de forte
croissance
la seule recherche du profit ne permet
pas de satisfaire tous les besoins
collectifs ni d'offrir des emplois et
encore moins sans doute de satisfaire
ses demandes d'emploi dans des zones
plus difficiles que d'autres
et je note ainsi un consensus sur cette
nécessité de se doter de nouveaux outils
et que évidemment l'économie solidaire
et sociale
en fait partie
bien sûr je me disais je vous l'avais
dit
d'économie sociale et solidaire ne va
pas résoudre
le chômage la désertification à laquelle
je faisais allusion tout à l'heure l'art
et industriels sont dans notre pays a
besoin
elle n'est d'ailleurs pas je crois que
vous l'avez aussi indiqué en août
irréprochable et nous savons qu'elle
effectivement progressé
mais
la question finalement
se pose d'où vient ce consensus en sa
faveur
je crois que le consensus ne vient pas
d'une idéologie ben là sans doute que
nous pourrions diverger les uns et les
autres
mais qu'elle vient d'une expérience et
d'une expérience que chacun de nous nous
faisons sur le terrain dans nos
départements nous avons chacun
l'expérience une entreprise de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui a
apporté quelque chose ne voulons pas
c'est que rien n'était possible et tout
d'un coup et bien tout devient possible
parce qu'une alternative au modèle
classique de l'entreprise
existe
le test que vous présentez le choc
ministre a une grande ambition et je
reprendrai les mots que vous avez
employé tout à leur proposer une autre
façon d'entreprendre
et je vous sais gré d'ailleurs d'avoir
aussi
illustré cette autre façon
d'entreprendre avec des propos de
philosophe
c'est une façon de placer le débat au
niveau où il doit se situer
il doit situer à ce niveau parce que
lorsque vous proposer une autre façon
d'entreprendre
chacun comprend qu'il s'agit d'une façon
d'entreprendre sans lucre et que dans le
monde dans lequel nous vivons voilà une
grande audace une audace que nous
partageons et que nous soutenons même
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
nous devons
le faire parce qu'aussi votre texte à un
autre mérite
c'est de ne pas tomber dans un mythe de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
mais au contraire d'apporter des
solutions concrètes
comment mieux définir ses entreprises
comment faciliter leur création comment
améliorer leur financement est
finalement assurer leur pérennité
pour la commission des lois
je proposerai de faire part des
réflexions de la commission des lois à
travers finalement une seule question
qui est une question évidemment de
synthèse comment favoriser le
développement de l'économie sociale et
comment elle a favorisé sous les angles
que vous avez indiquée c'est à dire la
définition de l'économie sociale et
solidaire mais tout a été dit donc je ne
reprendrai pas et nous sommes d'accord
notamment je veux saluer le rapporteur
au fond qui a tout à l'heure lui-même
cette phrase il était temps de donner
enfin une définition d'économie sociale
et solidaire à travers l'angle du
financement public à travers l'accès aux
marchés publics et plus généralement à
travers la dynamique de l'entreprise
le premier point c'est celle du
financement public qui peut prendre
différentes formes l'étude d'impact
d'ailleurs sur ce point et sur d'autres
me paraît d'excellente qualité
la première forme du financement public
c'est la subvention publique
et la subvention publique était devenu
est encore un objet juridique dangereux
c'est un objet juridique en jeu pour une
raison très simple c'est que il est
parfois difficile où elle est parfois
difficile à distinguer du marché public
lui-même et qu'un juge finalement peu
requalifié anna qui aurait dû relever
d'un marché ou d'une déviation services
publics requalifier en un acte qui
aurait dû relever du marché d'une
délégation de service public une
subvention et alors là c'est la
catastrophe rock planification ça veut
dire tout simplement remboursement est
donc ça veut dire sans doute faillite
liquidation judiciaire de l'entreprise
qui serait ainsi conservé il était donc
grand tranche repos vote l'expression de
sécuriser la notion de subventions et de
lui donner donc une définition la
commission des lois sur ce point je
salue et président de la commission des
lois a simplifié à proposer en tout cas
d une rédaction pour simplifier
simplement la définition le deuxième
point du financement public c'est
l'accès aux marchés publics
je note que
marchés publics en matière d'insertion
c'est quand même une part relativement
faible 5% pour les collectivités
territoriales 2 5% seulement pour les
marchés de l'état
donc nous sommes très loin évidemment
des objectifs que nous pourrions chérir
le texte avec pragmatisme va
proposer simplement qu'ils aient une
prise de conscience à travers ce schéma
de promotion des achats publics
socialement responsable au fond il
invite à un débat non pas une obligation
mais à débattre qu'est ce qui peut faire
le gré de clauses d'insertion dans nos
différents marchés je crois que c'est
évidemment un choix qui est excellent
qui va être pédagogique mais il faudra
peut-être un jour aller plus loin la
commission des lois propose elle de ne
pas retenir pour ce schéma un seuil qui
soit un seuil fonction du montant des
achats effectués mais qui soit un seuil
qui soit fonction de la démographie
ça nous sommes plus clair si on lit la
loi et bien si vous avez que le seuil
ses 30000 habitants cinquante mille
soixante dix mille 5000 da il ya matière
à discussion il nous en avons parlé avec
les missions de la sphère économique
voilà ça ne semble plus clair que de
renvoyer à un seuil à ces techniques de
montant des achats
j'indiquerai aussi que si les
collectivités territoriales sont invités
à faire davantage de marchés avec des
clauses d'insertion
il faut aussi vous me permettrez vue
sioniste de dire qu'il faut que l'état
lui-même augmente sa part mais je sais
que c'est votre souhait de type de
marchés publics 2 5% c'est évidemment la
moitié de l'effort aujourd'hui faut-il
parler d'efforts je ne sais pas en tout
cas la moitié de ce que réalisent les
collectivités territoriales le troisième
point dans cette financement public
ou en tout cas dans ces questions
globales de financement c'est une idée
remarquable
ce qui marche dont l'économie classique
c'est-à-dire les sociétés d'amorçage
transposons le à dans l'économie sociale
et solidaire et notamment à travers la
scop d'amorçage avec des règles souples
qui doivent favoriser l'apport de
capitaux
il y a une autre façon de faciliter ce
développement je n'en dirai pas
énormément que c'est l'objet même de nos
débats et ses bas sur l'article 11 c sur
l'article il ya une autre façon de
favoriser le développement
c'est de faciliter les possibilités pour
un salarié ou pour des salariés de
reprendre l'entreprise en cas de cession
ce point c'est l'objet de beaucoup de
discussions et vous me permettrez de
donner
l'avis de la commission des lois qui
finalement sans doute été proche pas
d'une façon unanime et dans une sa
majorité moi je trouve qu'il ya trop de
discussions sur cette question de de ce
droit prioritaire à une information ce
n'est qu'un droit prioritaire où c'est
un droit à une information prioritaire
ce n'est que ça mais c'est déjà
alors je crois qu'il faut pas dramatiser
le simple fait de donner cette priorité
d'information - chi machine le cas très
concret d'un boulanger qui part à la
retraite
le bourget part à la retraite il va
informer ses salariés
qui ont deux mois pour décider s'ils ne
décident pas si tout de suite il dit
mais nous ça nous intéresse pas on
abrège la durée des deux mois
pendant ces deux mois là est ce que on
pense vraiment que les banquiers vont
refuser leur aide que les fournisseurs
on se désengager et que les clients vont
voir ailleurs
d'abord je reviens tout à faire au texte
lui-même en principe il ya une clause de
discrétion qui devrait faire que cette
information là ne court pas la rue mais
on connaît évidemment les objections en
dix ans mais cette clause ne sera pas en
reste je voudrais quand même faire
observer que ces clauses existe déjà en
cas de cession si vous cédez votre
entreprise vous devez informer votre
comité d'entreprise et dans ce cas là
est bien le même risque évident de
divulgation d'information existent et
pour l'instant nous ne constatons pas un
débordement ou des effets pervers et
donc je crois qu'il faut aussi se fonder
sur cette expérience
moi je pense que en la matière au fond
nous devons faire confiance
aux règles bien connu mme ley de
l'économie de marché
ce qui va déterminer l'attitude d'un
repreneur
da banquier d'un fournisseur
ça va pas être l'information qu'on va
donner aux salariés c'est quoi c'est
l'état de l'entreprise
est ce que l'entreprise se trouve dans
une bonne situation financière
est ce que te se trouve dans une bonne
situation de compétition dans une bonne
situation sociale et si oui et bien
évidemment vous n'aurez pas les
banquiers qui partiront vous n'aurez pas
les fournisseurs qui diront maintenant
ça suffit et vous n'irez pas non plus
les clients qui ses frères donc revenons
simplement à ce que nous connaissons
c'est à dire aux règles de l'économie de
marché qui doivent nous permettre
paradoxalement peut-être de trouver une
solution aux inquiétudes qui sont formés
ici ou là
j'ajouterai
l'autre point est ce qu'on doit en
revanche donné un droit préférentiel de
rachat par les salariés
c'est une tentation qui peut exister
moi je tirais votre attention sur un
point
comment allons-nous où allez-vous pour
ceux qui veulent aller dans ce sens-là
justifier juridiquement qu'une offre de
reprise s'impose aux propriétaires d'une
entreprise qui se trouvera alors privé
de touche lors
comment d'ailleurs mettre en oeuvre un
tel droit préférentiel
par exemple le montant de l'offre des
salariés est-ce qu'il devra s'aligner
sur le monde en plus élevé des non
salariés
et si oui nous voyons le risque de
mauvais cadeau qui sera fait aux
salariés et sinon ces assises s'imposait
alors là nous allons être confrontés à
une difficile question constitutionnelle
je crois que
nous porterons à plusieurs principes
constitutionnels le premier c'est celui
du droit de propriété mais ce n'est pas
le seul fondement qui pourrait conduire
le conseil constitutionnel a annulé il
ya un autre qui était peut-être plus
couramment admis qui est le principe de
la liberté d'entreprendre et la liberté
contractuelle et si ceux qui on propose
un tel amendement ont des doutes sur ce
point eh bien je conseille aux joueurs
proposés consulter un arrêt récent du
conseil constitionnel du 13 juin 2013
qui justement sans sur un texte ce qui
était le texte sur la niche si je me
trompe pas
relatif à la liberté contractuelle il
reste que ce texte évidemment comme tout
texte peut être améliorée nous avons au
moment des amendements en particulier
pour la coalition nous souhaiterions que
pour les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés nous ayons une précision sur le
délai que nous maintenions le délai de
deux mois également pour les entreprises
de plus de 50 salariés mais cela fera
part de la discussion et puis je
voudrais aussi féliciter les auteurs de
ce texte pour toute la partie qui
concerne le droit associatif
voilà de nouvelles précisions qui vont
être très utile pour nos associations
qui vont leur offrir davantage de
possibilités pour acquérez aux
administrés et parfois vendre des biens
et des meubles c'est il me semble dans
l'état des choses vraiment une
perspective tout à fait intéressante et
donc la commission des lois a approuvé
l'ensemble de ces dispositions merci
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur gérard le cam
pour le groupe crc
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
madame et messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues
semaine dernière en bretagne plusieurs
milliers de travailleurs sont descendus
dans la rue pour crier leur colère et
leur désarroi alors que le chômage
augmente et que la liste des entreprises
en difficulté s'allonge gad doux tilly
sabco marine harvest 900 emplois
supprimés déjà en bretagne plus de 5000
menacé en 2013 un autre gros point noir
et psa peugeot citroën au tour de rennes
ce sont 1400 départs volontaires d'ici à
fin décembre et les effets en cascade
sur les sous traitants ce désespoir qui
tourne parfois à la violence n'est pas
propre à la région il touche toute la
france
au nom des sols signaux du marché les
entreprises se livrent au coeur de la
crise à la plus farouche concurrence du
coût du travail et des cours agricoles
les plus bas la lutte emblématique des
conti contre la puissance financière de
continental qui prétextant la crise en
2009 rayé de la carte une usine rentable
et 700 emplois a permis de dénoncer la
criminalité financière des actionnaires
qui invoquait des licenciements
économiques quand la valeur de leurs
actions doublait en 2012 et que le
chiffre d'affaires progressé de 17% le
combat des fralib pour faire vivre un
outil industriel de qualité alors qu
unilever décident de délocaliser en
pologne le tai l'éléphant créée à
marseille terreau vendu exclusivement en
france
la réalité économique et celle là et
elle appelle un changement de cap
radical dans la politique économique du
gouvernement et dans la gestion des
entreprises c'est pourquoi même si vous
avez bien précisé monsieur le ministre
que le projet de loi relatif à
l'économie sociale et solidaire est
volontairement limité aux entreprises
dites saines et fait le pari d'une
pollinisation vertueuse de l'économie
classique nous ne pouvons ignorer dans
nos débats l'urgence sociale et
économique à laquelle il faut réponse
dans notre pays nous sommes convaincus
que les salariés doivent être associée
plus étroitement à la gestion de leur
entreprise pour cerner les évolutions
connaître en amont les difficultés
pouvant survenir proposer un meilleur
partage des richesses créées des
évolutions techniques dans la production
intervenir sur la stratégie globale
nationale et internationale et les
segments d'activité de l'entreprise les
expériences menées en ce sens ont été
positives pour l'outil industriel comme
pour l'emploi dans ce contexte vous
comprendrez qu indépendamment de l'ordre
des articles je m'arrête d un présent
sur les articles 11 12 et 15 ces
articles emblématique du projet de loi
étendant le droit d'information à
l'ensemble des salariés en cas de
cession de l'entreprise ou du fonds de
commerce et instaurant la scop
d'amorçage constitue sans aucun doute
des mesures très positives elle nous
semble hélas bien isolée des articles 11
et 12 qui suscite la fronde du medef et
l'émoi de la droite ne vont pas assez
loin pour garantir une localisation des
emplois de l'activité économique pour
protéger les titres de propriété
intellectuelle
les brevets les marques un exemple pour
illustrer nos craintes dans le nord qu'à
l'ère entreprises de chimie a été vendue
et au moment de la vente
l'état a vendu ses parts et à récupérer
192 millions d'euros les salariés ont
proposé de reprendre l'entreprise en
gardant 117 salariés mais le projet a
échoué car il leur fallait 9 millions
d'euros le groupe axyntis va reprendre
le site mais ne conservera que 80
salariés voilà le type de situation que
nous voyons se multiplier dans le
territoire demain le projet de loi ne
garantira pas que le projet des salariés
qui pourtant maintien plus d'emplois
soit retenu en priorité c'est ce à quoi
nous devons travailler
c'est pourquoi vous proposeront des
amendements afin d'enrichir dans le
dispositif que vous proposez pour
accompagner les salariés mais également
pour leur reconnaître un droit de
préemption vous l'avez dit en
introduction monsieur le ministre
cinquante mille emplois sont détruits
chaque année parce que les entreprises
saines met la clé sous la porte faute de
repreneur d'autres emplois sont détruits
au nom de la rentabilité financière au
moment de la cession il est temps de
donner les outils aux salariés qui le
souhaitent pour reprendre leur
entreprise et défendre leurs emplois
c'est dans ce sens que nous souhaitons
comme le préconisait d'ailleurs le
conseil économique social et
environnemental
d'instaurer un droit de reprise dans un
délai raisonnable instaurer un véritable
droit de préférence au profit des
salariés renforcer le rôle des banques
coopératives dans l'octroi des prêts et
garanties en appui à leur projet nous
reviendrons sur cette question lors de
l'examen des articles 11 et 12 afin de
faire la démonstration qu aucun argument
politique ou juridique ne justifie à
notre sens que l'on renonce à un droit
de préférence au bénéfice des salariés
en ce qui concerne le droit à
l'information stricto sensu nous saluons
les avancées qui à l'initiative du
rapporteur au sénat cteur marc daunis
ont été actés par la commission des
affaires économiques l'article 11 ha qui
instaure un dispositif d'information des
salariés tout au long de la vie de
l'entreprise sur les possibilités de
reprise est essentiel pour garantir
l'effectivité du projet gouvernemental
dans cet esprit nous présenterons des
amendements visant à ce que les salariés
qui ont fait part au cédant leur volonté
de présenter une offre de rachat puisse
se faire assister par une personne qu'il
désigne dans des conditions définies par
décret afin qu'à la demande des salariés
cette personne puisse se faire
communiquer les documents comptables et
financiers de l'entreprise dans les
mêmes conditions que le comité
d'entreprise en application des articles
l 23 3,8 des ailes 23 3 9 du code du
travail nous vous proposerons également
que les salariés puissent se faire
assister par un représentant de la
chambre de commerce et de l'industrie
régionale de la chambre régionale
d'agriculture de la chambre régionale de
métiers ou de l'artisanat
territorialement compétente en lien avec
les chambres régionales de l'économie
sociale et solidaire nous proposons
également de compléter l'article 4 qui
définit les missions des chambres
régionales de l'économie sociale et
solidaire afin comme cela existe dans
certaines structures qu'elle anime un
espace régional de dialogue social qui
associe les organisations syndicales de
salariés
et d'employeurs nous pensons que ces
précisions conditionne fortement
l'efficacité du droit d'information et
l'appréciation de sa pertinence cela
d'autant plus que les autres
dispositions du projet de loi suscite
également des critiques sinon des
interrogations nous soutenons le projet
du ministère d'économie sociale et
solidaire de structure et l'économie
sociale et solidaire à travers une loi
réaffirmant ses principes fondateurs la
liberté d'adhésion la gestion
démocratique
la non lucrativité individuel l'utilité
collective ou l'utilité sociale du
projet la mixité les ressources la
diversité des acteurs de l'économie
sociale et solidaire est une première
difficulté qui apparaît lorsqu'on veut
rassembler cette grande famille le
respect à géométrie variable des valeurs
affichées est encore une autre question
les le projet de loi va plus loin dans
la difficulté puisqu'il tend par une
démarche inclusive d'intégrer les
sociétés commerciales dans l'économie
sociale et solidaire si nous comprenons
la dynamique qui guident ce choix nous
attirons votre attention sur les dangers
d'une pollinisation qui pourrait se
transformer en pollution du secteur pour
essayer de se prémunir contre un tel
risque nous vous proposerons de
renforcer les conditions posées à
l'article 1er du projet de loi qui
encadre la définition de le ss d'une
part nous souhaitons préciser la notion
de gouvernance démocratique
en effet s'il est vrai que le principe
un homme une voix ne régit pas la
gouvernance de tous les acteurs
historiques il reste qu'en l'état le
projet de loi est trop flou sur ce point
la gouvernance démocratique et
naturellement incompatible avec le dogme
de la primauté actionnariale cependant
on peut essayer de l'infléchir en
précisant que la gouvernance
démocratique défini est organisée par
les statuts prévoient la participation
non strictement proportionnelles à leur
apport en capital ou homo temps leurs
contributions financières des associés
est partie prenante aux réalisations de
l'entreprise nous ferons une proposition
allant dans ce sens d'autre part nous
vous proposerons également de renforcer
le caractère limité de la lucrativité
afin que les sociétés commerciales
puissent bénéficier du label économie
sociale et solidaire il nous sommes
important qu'elles jouent le jeu et par
conséquent qu'elle change certaines de
leurs pratiques dans la gestion de la
bénéfices c'est pourquoi il est
nécessaire d'augmenter les réserves
statutaires d'encadrer plus fortement
les bénéfices distribuables l'article 2
bis du projet de loi qui instaure une
déclaration de principe par laquelle les
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire peuvent signifier leur volonté
d'atteindre des objectifs plus
volontariste peut être considérée par
les plus sceptiques d'entre nous comme
un merveilleux exemple de droit mou de
droit soupes selon le qualificatif du
conseil d'état les plus optimistes y
verront un instrument non dépourvue
d'intérêt permettant un contrôle
démocratique de la politique affichée
par l'entreprise ayant retenu cette
dernière analyse nous vous proposerons
de mettre au coeur de ce texte
l'exemplarité sociale et d'inscrire
l'objectif de parité hommes femmes dans
les instances décisionnelles
enfin nous demandons que la liste des
entreprises adhérentes soit publié selon
des modalités prévues par décret et que
l'entreprise qui adhèrent à cette
déclaration en informe par voie
d'affichage les salariés et affiche
également la déclaration afin que les
principes vertueux atteignent les plus
hautes instances de le ss nous vous
proposerons de préciser la composition
du conseil supérieur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire afin de garantir
une représentation de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes du secteur notamment
des représentants des salariés et
d'assurer une réelle parité hommes
femmes en ce qui concerne maintenant
l'article 7 portant définition de
l'agrément entreprises solidaires
d'utilité publique il faut être très
prudent en effet cet agrément ouvre
actuellement droit à deux contreparties
qui sont l'accès d'une part des
entreprises solidaires au dispositif de
soutien fiscal dit sf pme et madelin qui
prévoit des réductions d'impôt sur la
fortune isf pme et d'impôt sur le revenu
pour le matelas au bénéfice de pme
investit dans les activités
technologiques ou présentant un
potentiel important de croissance le
volet solidaire de ces deux dispositifs
vient s'ajouter au volet technologique
et de croissance cet agrément se trouve
dans le projet de loi potentiellement
élargie notamment en direction des
sociétés commerciales qui remplirait les
conditions des articles l c'est pourquoi
ils sont primordiales afin que de grands
groupes
bénéficient pas d'être publics payés par
la collectivité
d'encadrer très précisément les
conditions d'octroi de l'agrément en
direction des sociétés commerciales
notamment l'écart maximum de
rémunération à respecter dans ce cadre
devrait prendre en considération pour
son calcul les primes de plus nous
pensons que l'agrément accordé de plein
droit ouvre une brèche dans le
dispositif d'accès aux aides publiques
en effet nous partageons les inquiétudes
de la majorité des acteurs des
entreprises solidaires d'utilité sociale
qui considère que cet agrément pourrait
engendrer une instrumentalisation du
conventionnement insertion par
l'activité économique par des sociétés
commerciales y voyant un moyen de
contourner les conditions d'obtention de
l'agrément d'entreprises solidaires
d'utilité sociale de plus on comprend
mal pourquoi le fait de mener une
mission d'utilité sociale permettrait de
s'affranchir de principes fondateurs du
secteur je voudrais pour finir faire
quelques remarques sur les dispositions
particulières concernant les acteurs
historiques du secteur tout d'abord nous
sommes très favorable à la révision
coopérative il s'agit de vérifier tous
les deux ou trois ans si l'entreprise
reste dans les clous de son statut de
coopérative avec tous les avantages et
toutes les aides que ce label représente
dans le cadre de le ss en revanche en ce
qui concerne les mutuelles le projet de
loi ne nous semble pas aller dans le bon
sens nous sommes très attachés à la
forme juridique mutualiste caractérisée
notamment par une gestion à but non
lucratif et solidaire qui permet de
prendre en charge les risques sociaux
alors même que les états abaissent leur
niveau de protection sociale obligatoire
le principe de démocratie qui devrait
être le mode de gouvernance des
mutuelles devraient permettre également
d'impliquer les citoyens dans les
décisions les concernant l'article 35 du
projet de loi sous couvert d'efficacité
va à l'encontre de cette règle alors
qu'il faudrait sortir les mutuelles des
directives européennes sur les
complémentaires et assurances et limiter
les obligations de réserves
prudentielles dans la tente du
remboursement à 100% par la sécurité
sociale le projet de loi crée un nouvel
instrument financier pour répondre aux
contraintes européennes que l'on dénonce
ce faisant il acte les décisions du
comité européen des régulateurs
d'assurance de ces upps
qui ne reconnaît pas la spécificité du
risque santé et veut imposer aux
organismes de complémentaire santé de
réaliser un montant de réserves
prudentielles largement surdimensionnée
ses exigences excessives et
inflationniste conduisent à des fusions
sous contrainte qui met à mal le système
mutualiste d'autres dispositions appelle
des réserves de notre part et nous y
reviendrons pendant l'examen des article
je pense ici au statut d'entrepreneur
salarié associé qui écarte
dangereusement un certain nombre de
travailleurs de la législation du
travail je pense également aux
dispositions sur les fondations et aux
niveaux titre fonda tiff qui ne nous
convainc pas et que nous proposerons de
limiter aux fondations reconnues
d'utilité publique le projet de loi sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire est
largement perfectible et nous espérons
pouvoir aboutir au terme des débats en
séance publique un texte plus ambitieux
qui constitue une première étape pour
préparer knees et nos emplois nos savoir
faire un texte qu'ils garantissent
également que les principes fondateurs
de la ss sortent renforcées et que
s'impose réellement une autre forme
d'appropriation des moyens de production
et d'échangé
je vous remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur jacques mézard
pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
aujourd'hui 21 21 mille coopérative plus
d'un million d'associations de mutuelles
ainsi qu'un nombre croissant
d'entreprises solidaires irrigue la vie
économique et sociale de notre pays elle
contribue au développement de nos
territoires
à la réduction des inégalités
qu'elles soient sociales aux
territoriales
l'économie sociale et solidaire
représente en effet plus de deux
millions d'emplois et 10% du pib
favoriser l'essor de ce secteur à
travers un ensemble de mesures
structurantes conférant un cadre
juridique simple et protecteur
facilitant l'accès au financement des
acteurs à les côtes de l'économie
sociale et solidaire
c'est donc un enjeu essentiel pour
l'emploi la croissance dans notre pays
mais aussi pour la solidarité la justice
et l'équité entre les citoyens et entre
les territoires
c'est pourquoi nous voyons favorablement
que le gouvernement présente aujourd'hui
en première lecture au sénat un projet
de loi qui doit permettre ce changement
d'échelle de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
on collègue stéphane mazars détaillera
tout à l'heure la position générale de
montgros ainsi que la logique qui
sous-tend les amendements que nous avons
déposés pour ma part je me concentrerai
sur deux articles qui ont au regard du
nombre d'amendements déposés retenu
l'attention de beaucoup de nos collègues
je parlais les articles 11 et 12 qui
instaure un dispositif d'information des
salariés en cas de cession de leur
entreprise
j'aimerais pour commencer rappelé
l'objectif poursuivi par ses articles
ils doivent permettre de sauvegarder des
emplois de maintenir de l'activité
économique aussi dans les territoires
ruraux où la transmission d'entreprise
est devenu souvent un problème très
préoccupant
dans ces territoires fragiles souvent
délaissé il convient de d'anticiper de
mieux préparer l'éventuelle cession de
l'entreprise avec quand c'est possible
bien sûr le concours des salariés quel
est le dispositif proposé pour parvenir
à de tels objectifs les articles 11 et
12 prévoit d'informer les salariés
lorsque le dirigeant décide de céder
l'entreprise
c'est bien normal et c'est d'ailleurs ce
que prévoit la directive la directive
européenne du 12 mars 2001 que la france
n'a toujours pas transposé
ensuite il s'agit de permettre aux
salariés parallèlement à l'information
qui leur est donnée de proposer s'il le
souhaite une offre de reprise nous
savons tous que lorsqu'une entreprise
est reprise par les salariés elle a
souvent plus de chances de perdurer et
je rappelle les chiffres qui figure
d'ailleurs dans le rapport 75% des
entreprises reprise par les salariés
existe toujours cinq ans après la
cession contre 60% des entreprises
transmises à un tiers les dispositions
du titre 2 vise donc à faciliter cette
reprise par l'information en associant
les salariés en amont afin notamment de
leur laisser le temps de formuler une
offre de reprise solide et crédible ce
dispositif est complété par l'article 11
a introduit par le rapporteur qui vise
plus généralement informer les salariés
sur les possibilités de reprise de leur
entreprise tout au long de leur vie
professionnelle
concrètement ces trois articles
devraient conduire à davantage de
reprise d'entreprise par les salariés
donc de réduire significativement
les fermetures d'entreprises en bonne
santé ce qui est une aberration de voir
des entreprises en bonne santé fermé car
il ya souvent l'absence de repreneur
mais aussi de favoriser le maintien de
l'activité et des emplois sur le long
terme ces mesures
peuvent constituer une avancée toutefois
il me semble qu'il reste encore beaucoup
à faire pour
permettre à des salariés d'être en
mesure de reprendre efficacement une
entreprise pour résumer sur le ministre
l'information c'est bien la formation
c'est encore mieux il y assure la
question de la formation professionnelle
de l'encadrement et de la préparation
des salariés à une possible reprise de
leur entreprise un véritable chantier à
développer et nous souhaitons que vous
alliez dans ce sens les membres de mon
groupe e sont favorables au droit
d'information instaurée par le projet de
loi considérons que c'est un progrès
pour autant la rédaction de ses articles
a suscité de vives interrogations
une expression et vous le savez nous
vous l'avons dit nous semble présenter
un risque non négligeable du point de
vue de la sécurité juridique celle de
l'intention de cession nous avons donc
cherché à proposer une nouvelle
rédaction afin de sécuriser ce
dispositif nous avons nous l'habitude
par tradition par l'expérience du
terrain et d'hommes de nos mandats
locaux auxquels nous sommes attachés de
rechercher des solutions équilibrées
respectueuse des intérêts de chacune des
parties ce texte
constituera un progrès économique et
social s'il est considéré comme un
instrument facilitateur et non comme une
contrainte par le chef d'entreprise la
france monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues se singularise en europe par
sa difficulté à sortir de blocage
idéologique souvent stérile freinant un
indispensable dialogue social
constructif
monsieur le ministre nous avons compris
que vous étiez prêts à prendre en
considération nos observations et nos
propositions et de fête de ce fait notre
groupe votera unanimement en faveur de
ce projet de loi
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame aline archimbaud
pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur rapporteur madame et
messieurs le rapporteur pour avis chers
collègues je souhaiterais commencer
cette intervention en saluant moi aussi
l'excellent travail de concertation mené
par le rapporteur marc daunis et le
remercier pour son écoute attentive
ainsi que tous les autres rapporteur
pour avis je souhaiterais également
apporté tous mes remerciements à
monsieur le ministre et à son cabinet
pour leur souci permanent d'un travail
constructif et pour leur disponibilité
malgré l'ampleur d'un texte comme
celui-ci et permettez moi de saluer
également outre les personnalités déjà
citer la présence en tribunes de
monsieur guy hascoët ancien secrétaire
d'état à l'économie solidaire jusqu'en
2002 et qui a tenu à nous honorer de sa
présence
de 2002
de 2002 à 2012 comme vous le savez cette
responsabilité ministérielle a été
supprimé et le projet de loi qu'il avait
préparé n'a jamais pu être examinés et
donc en effet aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre chers collègues c'est un grand
jour
cette loi la première venant définir et
encadrer le secteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire est une loi très
attendu par l'ensemble des acteurs est
depuis de nombreuses années depuis plus
de 30 ans en effet de nombreux citoyens
ont créé des réseaux d'epargne solidaire
d'accompagnement de soutien à des
porteurs de projets d'entreprise
d'économie solidaire soutenu
progressivement et de plus en plus par
les collectivités locales territoriales
et par des conseils régionaux
relayant ainsi et contribuant à
prolonger et à renouveler la belle
tradition de l'économie sociale né au
19e siècle au coeur de mobilisation
contre la misère sociale et n'ayons pas
peur de le dire c'est une très bonne loi
et le groupe écologiste souhaite lui
apporter tout son soutien
particulièrement en ce mois de novembre
qui est le mois de l'économie sociale et
solidaire alors ce projet de loi n'est
bien sûr pas totalement parfait c'est la
raison pour laquelle notre groupe a
déposé des amendements mais nous avons
conscience de la complexité d'allier la
vision d'un idéal et la réalité du
terrain ainsi que de concilier des
intérêts des conceptions parfois
divergentes et nous ne pouvons que nous
féliciter du pragmatisme mais l'exigence
du travail qui a été mené ici lors du
passage en commission le 16 octobre
dernier nous avions pu apporter notre
pierre à l'édifice sur les sujets de la
gouvernance démocratique de la parité de
l'affectation de la rentabilité
financière des entreprises de la
possibilité pour les sociétés
commerciales à capital variable de
racheter leurs parts sous certaines
conditions et sur la possibilité d'auto
saisine du conseil supérieur de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
mais c'est au niveau des territoires cet
échelon si chère aux écologistes et où
ils s'investissent depuis de nombreuses
années aussi bien en tant qu'acteur
économique militants que
en tant qu'élus locaux territoriaux
c'est au niveau des territoires que nous
nous réjouissons d'avoir obtenu des
avancées telles que l'élaboration par la
région d'une stratégie régionale de
l'économie sociale et solidaire intégrée
au schéma régional de développement
économique et d'innovation
l'organisation tous les deux ans d'une
conférence régionale de l'économie
sociale et solidaire ou encore le
renforcement du rôle des collectivités
territoriales dans les pôles
territoriaux de coopération économique
les articles 1 et 2 répondent bien à la
difficile tâche de définir le périmètre
protéiforme de l'économie sociale et
solidaire ainsi que celui de l'utilité
sociale plusieurs collègues avant moi
ont insisté sur ce point nous sommes
satisfaits de voir que le développement
durable et figure assagi à sa juste
place et à ce sujet je voudrais
souligner que pour nous l'économie
sociale et solidaire ne peut pas être
seulement définie par un statut
juridique l'essentiel est que le
périmètre
regroupent et soit ouvert à tous ceux
qui fournissent des produits et des
services utiles socialement
écologiquement et qui donc font l'effort
volontaires d'internaliser en amont des
coûts sociaux et environnementaux
trop souvent payés en aval par notre
société l'autre point important
concernant les définitions de ce
périmètre cela a été rappelé avant moi
et tant les critères de fonctionnement
démocratique et de gouvernance
démocratique
concernant l'article 4 si nous saluons
le renforcement des chambres régionales
de l'économie sociale et solidaire nous
déplorons néanmoins l'absence de mention
dans ce texte de structures assimilés
tels que par exemple les agences
régionales de développement de
l'économie sociale et solidaire le
groupe écologiste a donc déposé un
amendement en ce sens
concernant l'article 9 sur le sujet des
marchés publics sujet ô combien
important pour l'avenir de ce secteur
nous nous réjouissons que l'article met
en place un schéma de promotion des
achats publics socialement responsable
néanmoins
il nous semble important de mentionner
que ces achats doivent également être
environnement environnementalement
responsables et surtout de se fixer un
objectif chiffré par exemple de 20% des
achats publics à destination du secteur
l'économie sociale et solidaire ici
également le groupe écologiste défendra
d amendement dans ce sens à l'article 10
stères la réintroduction de la partie
concernant l'innovation sociale
réintroduction faite par le rapporteur
nous satisfait beaucoup mais il nous
apparaît pertinent que celui ci ouvre
aussi le droit au crédit impôt recherche
pour les entreprises de ce secteur car
nos entreprises ont souvent l'ambition
de viser aussi l'excellence
technologique loin des vision
misérabiliste parfois que le porter à
son sujet là aussi l'autre groupe a
déposé un amendement afin d'ouvrir ce
droit j'en viens à présent aux articles
sensibles souvent au coeur des débats
ces dernières semaines les articles 11 à
11 et 12 concernant le droit
d'information des salariés l'article 11
a introduit par le rapporteur marc
daunis marque une étape supplémentaire
et très importante vers une véritable
possibilité pour les salariés de
reprendre leur entreprise et nous nous
en félicitons
tout comme nous approuvons le délai
d'information des salariés deux mois
avant toute cession qui est introduit
par les articles 11 et 12 ainsi que
d'autres mesures déjà expliqué avant moi
est extrêmement importante c'est très
important et nous avons en tête de
nombreux exemples dans nos
circonscriptions dans nos départements
de nombreux exemples qui justifie ces
dispositions si nous voulons que le
droit à la reprise ne soit pas
simplement formelle et que les moyens
concrets soient donnés pour qu'il
devienne une réalité possible néanmoins
il nous paraît nécessaire de débattre et
d'aller plus loin au moins dans le débat
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
apportons ici notre soutien à notre
collègue marie noëlle lienemann c'est
pour cette raison que notre groupe a lui
aussi déposé des amendements afin de
mettre en place ou en tout cas de
débattre ici du rachat préférentiel à
offre égale pour les salariés nous le
rappelons il s'agit d'une promesse de
campagne du président de la république
et il nous paraît urgent que j'ai bien
entendu le rapporteur de la commission
des lois mais il nous paraît urgent
d'approfondir la réflexion de regarder
de près
comment les choses se passent et de voir
si on ne peut pas lever les obstacles de
façon à ce que des dispositions sur ce
sujet puisse être prise il y à là je
pense que vous avez tous en tête des
exemples un gisement potentiel colossal
d'emplois locaux de maintien d'emplois
le court et de redynamisation du tissu
économique en cette période de crise en
cette heure où il devient urgent de
répondre aussi à l'aspiration
démocratique exprimée par nos
concitoyens
l'économie sociale et solidaire démontre
qu'il est possible de faire autrement et
qu'il est possible d'avoir des
entreprises viables sur le plan
économique tout en respectant et en
mettant en oeuvre des valeurs de
solidarité et de de fonctionnement
démocratique
la crise économique sociale écologique
et là d'une ampleur terrible plus de
huit millions six cent mille personnes
vivent en france avec un revenu mensuel
inférieur à 964 euros et parmi elles
quatre millions cinq cent mille avec un
revenu mensuel inférieur à 7 116 euros
par mois et nous connaissons la cascade
des fermetures d'entreprises en ce
moment même devant de tels défis sociaux
et environnementaux
il n'est pas possible de refuser
l'innovation économique et social il
serait irresponsable que le gouvernement
le parlement ne saisissent pas
l'opportunité et les solutions que lui
proposent les acteurs les entreprises et
les réseaux de l'économie sociale et
solidaire en effet voilà un secteur qui
mobilise les citoyens les épargnants les
réseaux d'accompagnement dans
l'entreprise qui développe la vigilance
démocratique qui développe le lien
social c'est déjà un atout précieux pour
notre pays mais c'est aussi et cela a
été rappelé les chiffres ont été rappelé
et un secteur créateur d'emplois de
façon considérable et c'est enfin un
secteur d'avenir sur le plan économique
propre à nous aider à relever alizés
l'économie à la relever de ses
difficultés et dans de nombreux secteurs
services aux personnes petite enfance
création culturelle travaux publics je
pense par exemple à l'isolation
énergétique production distribution de
produits agricoles et alimentaires sains
industrie commerce équitable recyclage
circuit court en général services aux
entreprises la liste est longue alors il
est temps que la loi permette à côté des
deux autres secteurs économiques
aujourd'hui en place que sont le secteur
public et le secteur privé classique que
ce troisième secteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire soit reconnu à sa
juste place et que compte tenu de ce
qu'il apporte à la nation des valeurs de
solidarité et de démocratie qui ne se
contente pas de proclamer mais qu'il met
concrètement jour après jour en action
et c'est plus difficile qu'il soit
reconnu à sa juste valeur et qu'ils
soient soutenus par les pouvoirs publics
vu les enjeux en effet cela a été dit
l'économie sociale et solidaire doit
changer d'échelle sortir des simples des
sols expérimentation ou des petites
réalisations ce qui doit être à l'ordre
du jour c'est l'essaimage des
réalisations des savoir-faire déjà
accumulé depuis des décennies et c'est
le développement de projets à grande
échelle qui doivent être rendues
possibles par la loi je vous remercie
toujours dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est maintenant
monsieur gérard césar pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
économique monsieur le rapporteur marc
daunis et messieurs les rapporteurs
madame et monsieur le rapporteur mais
chaque collègue permettez moi de
commencer mon intervention par une
remarque en effet il n'est pas chose
aisée que de survivre à la balance
d'expression digne de monsieur de la
palisse qui nous a été donné d'entendre
cela le traditionnel verbiage autour des
nouvelles pratiques solidaires ou
d'utilité sociale je dirais même que
cette discussion générale touvre à
l'épreuve d'endurance malheureusement si
je me réfère à la rédaction de l'exposé
des motifs de votre projet de loi cela
n'a rien de très surprenant
en effet les premières lignes ne sont
pas sans rappeler ces manuels du type
l'économie expliqué aux enfants mais
plus inquiétant encore ce sont les
postulants écologique qui se manifeste à
chaque ligne et ensuite à chaque
disposition je n'aurais pas en cause le
droit du gouvernement a proposé un
projet de loi inspiré par les thèses
socialistes mais pour cela je regrette
encore une fois vous profitiez meja
collègues je vous ai écouté avec
attention ça vous interrompre je vous
demande de laisser la place à
l'opposition pour voir justement tenir
ces propos
vous dénoncez ensuite le modèle
capitalistique du classique basée sur la
maximisation des profits et donc sur la
dimension lucrative une activité vous
oublier trop vite que la russie cement
est un moteur puissant pour l'homme et
pour les peuples et que les français ont
le droit d'avoir une ambition
individuelle celle d'améliorer leurs
conditions ce qui passe nécessairement
par l'argent aussi pour montrer en quoi
votre projet de loi relève et
l'oenologie dépassés même s'il se
complaît la confiscation du type nouveau
référentiel économique je concentrerai
mans pour l'intervention sur deux
aspects de ce projet de loi deux aspects
qui ont été soulignés par tous les
intervenants d'abord les dispositions
déterminant le champ de l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui serviront de
base à l'obtention de l'agrément
entreprises solidaires d'utilité sociale
ensuite les fameuses dispositions
afférentes aux droits d'information des
salariés
nous y voilà
à ce qui concerne la détermination du
champ de l'économie sociale et solidaire
ce projet de loi s'adresse directement à
l'économie du service à la personne nous
admettons sa réserve que ces secteurs
d'activité mérite la réflexion
nous allons lui consacrer nous
connaissons tous les chiffres 11
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
et près de 2 millions de salariés mais
surtout ce secteur d'idéal pour lutter
contre le chômage de longue durée en
s'adressant aux populations les plus
sensibles
en effet nous savons
82 % des employés du secteur n'ont pas
le bac et 40% des salariés déclarent
qu'ils n'avaient pas d'emploi auparavant
mieux encore les effectifs salariés ont
progressé en 2011 de 16 % ce secteur est
effectivement un réservoir d'emplois et
de croissance la situation du secteur du
service à personne est donc la suivante
nous avons un secteur dont l'offre est
en pleine croissance mais la croissance
et offre ne serait couvrir totalement la
croissance de la demande des
opportunités sans précédent
s'offrent à notre économie il convient
donc de stimuler l'offre en matière de
services à la personne
malheureusement si on regarde dans le
détail des dispositions déterminant le
champ de l'économie sociale et solidaire
j'en viens à me demander si votre cadeau
c'est le ministre n'est pas empoisonnée
pour rappel ces dispositions qui
permettent entreprise ou une association
d'intérêt l'économie sociale et
solidaire sont primordiales car le
rendent éligible
auprès de la bpi elles détermineront
ultérieurement l'obtention de l'agrément
entreprises solidaires d'utilité sociale
celui-là même qui rend éligible au
dispositif du soutien fiscal isf pme et
madeleine si nous en paierons pas par
principe à votre dispositif de soutien
fiscal rendue possible par l'obtention
de l'agrément entreprises solidaires
d'utilité sociale nous nous opposons
fermement aux conditions d'obtention de
cet agrément ainsi que conditions
d'intégration dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire en effet que dit l'article 1er
sur les conditions d'intégration de
l'économie sociale et solidaire celui ci
prévoit que les sociétés commerciales
souhaite intégrer l'économie sociale et
solidaire prévoit un prélèvement d'une
fraction au moins égale à 15 % des
bénéfices affecter la formation d'un
fonds de réserves dites réserves
statutaires un prélèvement d'une
fraction au moins égal à 50% des
bénéfices affecté report bénéficiaires
ainsi qu aux réserves obligatoires et
enfin l'interdiction du rachat par la
société d'actions ou de parts sociales
mais en plus de ces restrictions propres
sociétés commerciales ces dernières
devoir avoir un but un but poursuivi
pour autre que le seul partage des
bénéfices exigences wable et surtout
invérifiable quel est le but ces
restrictions sans doute empêcher que les
groupes les plus importants entre dans
le champ de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et puissent bénéficier du
soutien fiscal nous comprenons votre
inquiétude
mais la rédaction de l'article 1er est
comme un filet aux mailles trop étroites
qui empêchera l'immense majorité
d'entreprises commerciales du secteur
d'intégrer l'économie sociale et
solidaire mais quelles sont ces
entreprises c'est très simple 65% des
entreprises
évoluant dans le secteur des services à
la personne compte moins de 5 salariés
eux mêmes ces très petites entreprises
sont en prise dans les mailles de votre
fils est par exemple même l'auto
entrepreneur qui n'est pourtant pas un
danger pour les acteurs non commerciaux
du secteur ne pourra pas entrer dans
l'économie sociale et solidaire du fait
de ces exigences irréalistes par
comparaison
les réserves légales d'une entreprise
seule réserve obligatoire par défaut
pour une entreprise s'élève à 5% du
bénéfice l'exercice diminué de
l'éventuel report à nouveau débiteur
nous sommes bien loin les exigences
gouvernementales pour entrer dans le
texte économie sociale et solidaire que
dit ensuite l'article 7 sur l'obtention
de l'agrément entreprises solidaires
d'utilité sociale il faut pour cela que
l'entreprise fasse la preuve que la
charge induite par son objectif
d'utiliser social affecte de manière
significative le compte de résultat ou
la rentabilité financière de
l'entreprise cette disposition me paraît
pour le moins incertaine en effet selon
que nous avons une conception étroite
heures ou souples les impacts financiers
de ces charges l'essentiel des sociétés
commerciales du secteur pourrait être
soit exclue dispositifs soient intégrés
ainsi l'addition de l'article 1er est de
l'article 7 conduire à exclure la
majorité d'entreprises du secteur des
services à la personne de l'économie
sociale et solidaire et de lac léman
entreprises solidaires d'utilité sociale
aussi pour remédier à cette lacune notre
groupe ump présentera des amendements
qui auront pour objet d'assurer
l'intégration des sociétés commerciales
du secteur dans le dispositif auquel
elles peuvent légitimement prétendre
pourquoi soutenons sa déposition tout
simplement parce que ce projet de loi
s'il venait à être adoptée en l'état en
l'état créerait une distorsion de
concurrence au détriment sauter
commercial évoluant dans un secteur des
services à la personne celles ci seront
privés de soutien fiscales dans leurs
principaux concurrents
associations ou avant d initiation qui
pourront en bénéficier
or ces petites sociétés commerciales
n'ont pas les moyens d'évoluer sur le
même marché que des agents économiques
sans but lucratif certes mais qui
vinifie d'avantagés fiscaux conséquents
second point de ce projet de loi qui
suscite de vives interrogations le droit
d'information des salariés
article 11 et 12 nous avons discuté et
j'ai repris hier en commission ce matin
prévoit à nouveau une forme nouveau
droit d'information préalable des
salariés en cas de transmission d'une
entreprise saine quelle est la finalité
de ces dispositions exposé des motifs
explique qu'il s'agit de préserver la
viabilité de l'entreprise et d'assurer
la pérennité de l'activité et de
l'emploi vous explique également que ce
nouvel outil doit permettre le recours
société coopérative et participative
cependant nous semble que ce dispositif
est assis sur un mécanisme dont les
contours sont encore très incertaine en
effet les articles 11 et 12 dispose que
la cession par son propriétaire d'une
participation d'un fonds de commerce ne
peut intervenir avant l'expiration d'un
délai de deux mois cet été ce matin nous
avons un examen des membres ou trois
mois six mois un an etc mais donc c'est
le rapporteur a proposé ce été suivi par
la commission que ce soit un délai de
deux mois à compter de la date de
notification
j'ai reçu responsable de la commission
des lois
qui fait son intention de vendre vous
l'aurez compris nous sommes dans le
meilleur des cas dubitatif à l'endroit
de cette exposition et notamment ce qui
concerne l'utilisation d'expressions
intention de vendre le terme et tensions
nous semble source de profonde confusion
n'est pas ici question de démarche
proactive de recherche des repreneurs
qui peut se manifester formellement mais
il est simplement question d'intention
or je ne vois pas que l'acte formel peut
être attaché à l'intention de vendre
soit il s'agit d'une décision dans ces
cas-là l'arsenal désactive existe déjà
soit il s'agit d'interrogation dans ce
cas les questionnements des
propriétaires n'ont pas vocation à être
publics se soucient de bien faire le
projet de loi prévoit que les salariés
sont tenus à une obligation de
discrétion
à l'égard des informations communiquées
si la précaution me semble bienvenue je
n'en vois pas comment elle pourrait
s'appliquer concrètement autre source
d'inquiétude la baisse d'attractivité
pour cette disposition entraînera ses
petites entreprises souvent intégré un
tissu économique complexe seront exposés
des tentatives de déstabilisation
mais au-delà de ce risque direct le
droit d'information rendre à la reprise
d'entreprises moins attractive pour les
repreneurs étrangers qui dans leur
grande majorité soutiennent un vrai
projet industriel
ensuite vient la question de l'offre de
rachat que les salariés peuvent réaliser
une fois l'intention de vendre
communiqué dans ce cas nous pouvons que
regretter que le texte ne prévoit pas de
dispositions visant à prévenir tout
risque de propositions de rachat qui
viserait uniquement à ralentir
d'éventuelles cessions
aussi nous estimons que ce droit
d'information préalable salariés en cas
de transmission d'entreprises saines et
dans le meilleur des cas superflu
lorsqu'il n'est pas en danger la
viabilité d'une activité économique en
exercer revend les craintes et salariés
même si celle ci se justifier à ce qui
concerne le rejet
du projet de loi nous émettons quenum je
veux dire à ce qui concerne le reste du
projet de loi nous émettons quenum
dispositions qu'ils interdisaient relève
du bon sens monsieur le ministre vous
écoute quelque chose qui va peut être
positive il est en effet question de
sécuriser juridiquement et de simplifier
la vie des acteurs de l'économie sociale
et solidaire entreprises associations